Yeah.
Ah,
what does that, it's breathing. It's
power breeding folks into the nose,
out through the mouth. I thought
you were about to finish. No,
that's not how I roll. I'm more
grunt. Like it's more primal and sad.
Ultimately the Joe Rogan experience on
a quest for enlightenment is just trying
to get rid of loads.
The Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by
speaking to getting rid of
loads.
The fleshlight fleshlight is
the number one sex toy for men.
It has a very unique blend of shit
that was pulled out of the earth and
converted firms and spicy oil and,
and petrol chemicals into
some crazy fake pussy tissue.
That is outstanding.
It really does work.
And we have to be honest here.
And the honesty is you've got an a fucking
masturbator right? And if you're not,
if you're not only not
being honest with yourself,
you're not being kind to yourself.
What do you want to do?
You want to walk around confused all day?
Do you walk around tortured
by the thoughts of sex?
Just some physical act that you need
to accomplish and why? So sir, why?
I'll tell you why,
because you got this crazy body that
used to be a monkey body 10,000 years ago
were essentially the same except we
were running from saber tooth tigers.
I'll get where that same body and that
same body didn't have vaccines and they
didn't have doctors. It
didn't have anything, so he'd
fucking died off like crazy.
So in order to keep the population live,
it's engineered inside of us
that we have to fuck a lot.
And you can do that and you can choose
to do that and you can be that guy.
Primates did it with frogs. Yeah,
you can do with polyurethane. Yep,
exactly. What I'm, when I'm
advising is just body maintenance,
ladies and gentlemen,
and,
and get away from this crazy puritanical
idea that we're not supposed to discuss
masturbation and that men aren't supposed
to have awesome sex toys like the
fleshlight.
All right ladies,
you're vibrators in your dildos have
been a source of humor for years.
He, he ha ha, I'll just use my vibrator.
And that seems to be okay with you.
That's like some sort of an empowerment,
but yet a man buying a flashlight is
to be ridiculous. Ridiculed. Okay.
We need the fan belt car battery driven.
Fleshlight cause they have
fucking machines but guys
don't necessarily have it.
Man. You don't want to get addicted. If
you ever met a girl to addicted to her,
I was trying to help you sell
a flashlight. That's all I
hear you. Thank you. Yeah.
And it kills it because they get
addicted to that more than sex.
Like that sensation is, it's better
than a dick just slowly sliding in you.
You're like, it's, it sucks. You can
fuck your pussy up forever. It is true.
It is real. I, I have met girls who are
very honest about it. He said, you know,
their husband can't get them off anymore.
They have to use a vibrator.
And you're like, wow,
what happened? I've never,
never actually been with a girl like
that, but I was scared of him. Man. If I,
if I talk to some girl and you know,
we're,
we're getting to know each other
and she was like, you know, hey,
I'm just really into vibrators and
she'll let you know like right up front I
collect,
have you seen my double tapered
vibrating colossal Qing Dong?
It's like, you know that scares me.
She's used to flying at high g's.
You know the thing that a
vibrator can do to you, it's just,
it's just a totally different thing.
Like that's an artificial thing that
you've become addicted to honey.
So I don't want that.
So I don't think that I need anything
other than what the f I think the
flashlight is perfect. I don't even think
they need to innovate. How about that?
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight.
Use the code name Rogan and save yourself
15% off the number one sex toy format.
So they,
and they did, they do have sex toys for
women now they actually have, Lilo is air,
which is like some of the, the high end
Porsche versions of vibrators for women.
So wow. Fuck your pussy up of those. So
there you go. You can get that too. Yeah.
If you're really into that, we really
want to break that day, you know.
Do you know Sam triple? He's actually
doing something with flashlight, isn't it?
Yeah,
he's tall.
He's doing like a man on the street
thing at comic con with reflecting is
perfect for that Sam
Tripoli's and as an animal,
he's doing men on the street
with flashlights. Yeah. I
don't know what that means,
but
Oh gee, Microsoft, uh, really a
runtime error. You got it too. Yes.
I got one today. Abnormal program
termination halfway. You go fuck yourself.
Listen, we love these alien alien
where computers are bad ass.
And I like them because the
Alienware sponsors MMA fighters.
And if you're really into games,
and I must admit I'm not anymore,
but fucking God damn. If I was,
this thing would be amazing.
You play anything on this and high
resolution, high screen, high frame rates.
I'm playing portal two in three
D, right? That's fucking bad ass.
But everything around it drives me crazy.
Microsoft could suck a dick man.
To be fair.
She never alien.
Where'd it was not responsible for that
runtime error in any way, shape or form.
Some way it's,
it's hard to believe how many
viruses there are for Microsoft,
for windows.
When you look at it online and like the
actual numbers of viruses that exist,
you go, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait
a minute. It's like the blood is this,
this is,
this is craziness.
There are hundreds of
thousands of viruses,
hundreds of thousands of
things that you can get.
Many of them html based viruses.
Sure.
We just have to click on a link and boom,
you're fucking cool.
In fact, you just want to chat
with a hot single in your area.
Suddenly your entire email address is
owned by somebody in Czechoslovakia,
so I did something pretty
cool to recently to my Mac.
There's a program that Norton gives
out in the APP store that's free in it
detects for malware and viruses
and everything like that.
Now I have malware,
malware and it's, well,
it's like a bunch of shipping
bills. Ed's coming to me.
I'm not used to saying it because
I'd never have to deal with that. No,
it's not a word you say. No, you're right.
I don't think I've ever said it
before either. Honestly. I have about,
I don't know,
five computers,
MACs and most of them are
just the dirtiest Max ever.
Like downloading the grossest worst
torrents and crap and nasty shit I had
downloaded on all of my
computers and I ran and now
not even one little baby thing.
No virus, nothing. I don't know.
People will talk a lot of shit
like people that are in windows,
Mac and cheese get viruses too and
you're like, just name one name one.
Did they ever really come up with
Kevin would know all about this?
They certainly, we should hold this.
That's,
I was being quick.
That's the problem with doing these
commercials like this and he said they
become sometimes a podcast in
the middle of a commercial.
That's what they're kind of good
though. Awesome. Yeah, that's true.
Alienware invest. Well alienware's
isn't even our sponsor. They just said
a company called Sucker
Punch entertainment and it's
got a sweet deal on these
laptops.
I did it specifically to try to support
a company that supports MMA because
these guys sponsor a lot of up
and coming fighters and it's cool.
I think that's huge. So, uh, you
know, but Microsoft can suck a dick.
Yeah,
I said it.
I might turn this to tap in a tablet
and that tablet can suck my dick,
whatever that tablet,
Microsoft, but the new surface.
Why are you mad at the surface? And
we need to start. I was like, come on.
We need to, we need to get the
music going. We also sponsor,
we're also sponsored by [inaudible]
dot com on nootropics. I love them.
You can try this stuff and make him
your cell phone lines. You can do that
kettle bells now and battle ropes. I
just got my battle ropes in the male son.
I should make a video showing a video
of me hulking out with the battle ropes.
I've got do that.
It's an APP that's malware bitch
malware, detect malware. And it's um,
if you've, if you've never
done kettlebells before,
it's, you should really,
if you can, you should get personal
instruction. That's what I believe.
If there's a gym near you or a crossfit
gym where they could show you the right
way to do it.
I've had the very good fortune to have
had a few different instructors and have
someone physically there.
It makes a big difference.
There's plenty of videos though online.
As long as you start out with very
manageable weights and believe it or not,
you can get a great workout.
I can still to this day,
even though I've been lifting kettle
bells for years with one 35 pound
Kettlebell,
I mean there's this crazy workout that
this guy has that I have no affiliation
with.
It's called the extreme kettlebell cardio
workout and I've said this and now his
DVD is totally sold out everywhere. It's
really hard to find now. And, and I,
I it's that good though. It's
not good. This guy should,
he should get all that money in more for
free. For me, it's, it's, it's amazing.
I recommend it to everybody all the time
because it is one of the most brutal 40
minute workout ever and it's one 30
pound Kettlebell, 35 pound countable
seems like nothing. The first
couple times you do it, it's like,
well you're activating every muscle
in secondary movers for balance.
You're constantly engaged head to toe,
you're using your hold,
but the concept behind kettle bells is
that you're using your whole body as one
unit as opposed to things like a lot
of people like they think of lifting
weights is like bicep
curls or tricep extensions.
That's actually kind of an unnatural
way to exercise and it actually usually
creates imbalances because if
you're not, you know, real careful,
like if you do a lot of quad exercises,
you got to do hamstring exercises to fuel
on a biceps. You have to do trust them.
So I get, and then you also probably
have to balance your backout as well.
Like your,
your whole body as a whole is a much
better option using your body as a whole.
And you can do it with less weight, which
it's a really amazing thing. It does.
You're conditioning your,
your weightlifting and your conditioning
all in one big group instead of a,
the way most people do it,
like by breaking things up and sets
it's way more fun and it translates to
anything you were trying to do,
like physical,
if you have a sport that you're trying
to do that involves strength and a and
speed endurance, kettlebells will
help you fucking tremendously.
So we just started carrying them. There's
a bunch of great deals on them. Um,
we're, we're selling them literally
as cheap as we can sell them there.
It's really the like, oh
dude, it's ridiculous.
The logistics of a small
company like on it, you know,
I mean basically we've only been
around for like a year. You know,
a company like this,
it was mostly selling nutrients to all
of a sudden goes to selling these fucking
cannon balls.
These things are huge,
but they're the best quality you can buy.
Are you guys drop shipping them or you
have like storage space now and you're
buying
storage space? The whole
thing. It's crazy. Yeah. It's,
um, you know, it's, it's,
there's a lot involved in it,
but what we're concerned with is that
we're selling you the best shit available.
And these kettlebells or York kettle
bells or the best kettle bells you can buy
their fucking perfect. I have
him in my house. They're,
they're absolutely perfect and
they'll last for a million years.
They're cast iron.
You don't need a gym.
You need a couple of these kettle bells
and some youtube videos and you will
have workouts for the rest
of your fucking life. I mean,
there's a million free videos out
there showing all sorts of different
exercises. People, you know,
put themselves to these
crazy crossfit routines.
And there's,
there's high weight,
low rep routines and there's
every kind of exercise.
All you need to do is look online
anyway on a.com is where it's at.
Get the kettle bells.
We have the battle ropes and,
and when it comes to nootropics,
any of the things that,
whether it's Alpha brain or a shroom
tech sport, which is an awesome uh,
endurance supplement
or shroom tech immune,
which is a supplement that actually
contains a mushroom that tricks your body
into thinking that it's got a cold.
So your body fires up its immune system
thinking that the mushroom is like a,
like a cold, but it's not, you're
just over clock and your body. Yeah.
You just giving your body something
leaves your body like gets pumped up for a
fight. That never happens. And so you
know, if you come into a common cold,
you when to find a better chance.
Don't, don't keep your on, don't
keep your on it products in your car.
If it's hot outside by the way,
because it melts into like an on
it ball and I knew she'd just take,
just take the whole fall, stuff it up
your ass. Take it anal like an apple.
That's how you eat your apples
up your ass. No, no, no.
Eat it takes her as asshole like a
horses mouth. He's got a feed bag
hanging over it right now.
It's got a tongue. Whoa,
settle the fuck down kid. Uh,
anyway,
uh,
use the code Dean Brogan and you will
save yourself 10% off any and all
supplements. Uh, there's
100% money back guarantee.
If you order a shroom tech,
have you ordered Alpha brain,
whatever you ordered the first 30 pills,
if you decide that it doesn't do as
advertised or do a enough to satisfy you,
you just say the stuff socks and
you get 100% of your money back.
You don't have to return the product.
We're way more concerned with making
sure that nobody feels ripped off and way
more concerned that everything that we
sell has to be something that I 100%
totally believe in. And so that's
why we have this set in place.
So let's say it's as easy as possible to
get your money back, right? That's it.
Pitches.
Do you have the music?
Kevin Pereira is here a free man
out in the sphere of the world.
No longer under any type of contracts
all day.
Dj Brian does it. Yen in the MIB. Amen.
He's silly bitch.
How dare you.
I dare you come up with new ways
to be silly ladies. Gentleman,
Kevin prayers here. Brian. We for
sure on the right channel. Yeah,
I ladies and gentlemen,
we know for sure we're on the right show.
That same shit scares the fuck out
of me. What just happened? Right?
Time error like jasmine pop up,
new stuff that we got ahold of
this new uh, new God powder. Yeah.
This new mothers creation. There's a,
it's a, it's a type of pod called Sativa.
You know what that is, right? I've
heard of it a little bit about that.
I read a Wiki or to have
it on the interwebs. This,
it's called sage. Yes. The,
the name of this one particular strain.
It's,
it doesn't seem like
Potts should be different.
That one should really have that
much of a different impact on you.
But some of 'em, some of 'em man, you get
ahold of me and go, okay, what's this?
Yeah,
what the Hell is this?
It's like, it's like when
you, when you, you know,
you get Tequila blackout a few times
and someone introduces you to whiskey.
Now this is, this is supposed
to be the same exact thing.
Yeah. But it's completely
different. How is that, man,
why is Tequila different than
whiskey? Is it because, uh,
most people want to say that alcohol is
just alcohol and if you're drunk on wine,
you're drunk and beer. It's
all the same. Yeah. I don't,
but it doesn't seem to be that.
What does that, it doesn't at all.
I mean, it's gotta be because of the,
I'm trying to think of the environment.
Like let's say normally when you have
Tequila, I would say you're probably, um,
you're probably gonna have a shitty
Mexican restaurant somewhere, right?
There's a Mariachi music in
the background and you're,
you're all those senses combined give
you a very different drunk feel. Right?
Not True at all. I've had Tequila in
multiple settings. It's the same filthy,
vomiting, blackout high.
For me, it's a dangerous is
due. Like I can't drink it. It's, there's
something about decision making. This is,
I like looking at it and I go like,
this is going to be four days of hell.
Yeah. Being drunk, man.
What a fucking weird idea to take humans
and they voluntarily inject something
into their system,
swallow something that tastes awful and
all just to be free of themselves for a
little bit.
Yup.
In the fact that that is the one that
you and I can go easily and quickly and
legally consume and then get behind
the wheel of a car and do all sorts of
tragic stuff that is just
murderous and torturous to society.
And yet that is the one
that is completely legal.
It's so hilarious that our system is set
up this way in this day and age and the
base of the past when they
could lie and what we,
but now that we have on the information,
the fact that it's set up like this,
like you mother.
Well, and the fact that,
look, I don't give, I hate
political polls. I hate polling.
I don't trust any of that shit.
I never get called for him.
I don't know anybody else that does not.
Apparently they're pulling the nation,
but the majority of this country actually
wants it to be decriminalized and
legalize. And even with all the Info
and the political weight behind it,
not going to happen anytime.
Yeah.
And,
and what you were saying about Paul's like
who the fuck is answering those poles?
Who's the people who still answer their
phones when they get a call on their
landline?
Maybe youth there QBC and take another
Werther's original and take a poll.
What the fuck is taking polls really
pulls him was one of the most ridiculous
things ever. Because all you're
going to get is people that are busy
and it's just people that have
nothing to do. You're on TMZ.
Do you ever do the polls? What
are the polls like? Is She hot?
Is she not well, those poles
matter in this world. I can.
Those kinds of posts are
the ones that matter.
No Man, I don't, I don't go on
any poles. I'm not, I don't,
I'm not fucking filling anything out.
I know I'm not no interest,
no interest to ask.
Yes. Consumer questions.
When I, when I'm on like the, when I'm
on the telephone and it pops up with the,
hey, if we press one, if you're okay
with a three to five minute survey,
at the end of this call, I go, yeah, I'll
press one. Because in my head somewhere,
a flag pops up on a computer
and tell somebody that my call,
he's going to lead to feedback.
I don't actually take the survey,
but I go out of my way
to say it. Yeah, yeah.
I'll take the survey after the call and
you just become a random in the system.
Probably. I'm a, I'm a ghost in the
machine somewhere, number generator,
and you just fucking with their
numbers pretty much for no reason.
You hacked her numbers. You know when
those cars are in the, in the malls w uh,
that,
uh,
like it says like sign up to win this
car that's signing up to become on the
worst spam mailing list ever.
You'll start getting phone calls and spam
your business card in the fishbowl at
a restaurant or is there like,
you're just,
you're just giving away
your info at that point.
You're saying please mark the tiny,
somebody did that,
did that for a living and he says,
dude,
they just make so much money cause
collecting like hundreds and of people's
complete like information addresses.
Everything they do is they,
you have to fill this shit out and then
you put it in and it's worth it for them
to give away a car to get
all that information yet.
But by the time they get enough,
they're selling your information and
getting a lot of money in that car.
Is it nothing to the amount of money?
It's worth thousands and
thousands of people's information.
How do you think they'd do it?
Do you think they'd go to have like
Volvo and make a deal and they say,
hey listen, we're going to give your car
away. I think they go and they say, Ah,
this $20,000 car or the $70,000
cars going to be an investment of x,
we're going to get y for their
data that that's a done deal.
They'll just buy the car and
set up something like that.
So you don't even think they
do it through the car company?
I think they just buy it. They'd probably
go to some sweet promotional discount.
They'd probably get refurbished cars
somehow. Cardone's he's themselves.
We'll do that just to get,
collect data on people who are interested
in that vehicle and willing to go out
of their way to look at it.
So they're doing it themselves.
There's independent companies that are
doing it, selling it to them. Right.
But when you have like a Cadillac CTSV
showcased in a mall and then you can win
that. I think I've got to think
Cadillac is paying for that. No, no,
but in some cases, yeah, I
bet some pilot times. Yeah.
Like if there's a new car that just
came out and they're trying to draw
attention to it, then they might
work something about the mall.
But if you go to most malls,
it's just some random cars sitting there
and it's like win a trip to Hawaii or
something like that.
Does.
The pro tip is when you meet
somebody you don't like in this life,
when you're networking or whatever,
the pro tip and real life in life, man,
it's a real life pro tip, right?
As a wall hacking and battlefield,
this shit's gonna help you
out in real life. Okay.
What does it take the business card to
someone you absolutely hate when you're
networking and just make sure you toss
it and all of those balls at the malls do
make copies of it. Yes, absolutely. Spread
there. Cause this quarter and everyone,
why do you have a stack
of my business cards?
Just want to let people know
you're awesome. Yeah. I'm
your number one fan bro.
Jesus Christ. Yeah. It's a
weird thing that people want
to collect that much data,
isn't it?
That's that's what's important.
You're reaching the most amount of people.
We ain't able to sell them things.
Being able to convince them
to sell you a sell you things.
What the fuck do you think is going on
in Nigeria that makes them so good at
scamming?
I mean there's one place in Africa that's
like really known for crashing dudes
thinking that it's like a girl and
it's just a Nigerian man behind it.
It's like tricking or my, the, the, the,
the high priest of the land or whatever
has millions of dollars tied up in a
bank account. We just need $10,000 and
a little info from you to get it out.
Those kinds of scams as well.
I bet they have just like
endless pictures of a woman.
I would say that's what they started so
they can, here's me here, here's me there.
You know, you could just, I love the
people that fuck with the scammers back.
Have you seen those sites? Yes. Look,
we would really love to
give you $1 million and we
haven't, we're ready to do it.
We just need you to get completely
replace your mouth with stalag tights.
If you could just get that operation
done or put diamonds in all of your teeth
and then record yourself
singing the, uh, the, the,
the theme tobacco back to
life for facts of life. They,
they're like make them go out of their
way to do crazy shit to release the money.
Oh yeah. Really? Yeah. And
I sent an email, they'll
sing songs and record video.
Someone had them shoot like promos
wearing specific like tee shirts and stuff
for his company. It was great.
He scanned the scammers.
How many times have the
scammers one though?
I mean they must enough to make it worth
doing time and time again and still do
it from this day and age.
How many things are doing it?
Do you think it's like a real business
in Nigeria? I would assume so.
I mean if gold farming and Diablo
can be an industry in China,
you know like that was the game
came out on the day it was released.
There were bots and they were communities
and there were sites to all the non
dorks. Exactly what you
mean. So, uh, all right.
So when see us folks,
when we were busy not having sex,
we figured out games to play and
Diablo is one of them. And you can buy,
there's a real money and
a virtual currency auction
house in the game so you can
use that currency to buy new stabs and
swords and pieces of armor and flair and
it'll give you a poison resistances.
It's really intricate shit,
very important stuff.
So you can use that goal to get it,
but some gamers don't want to spend the
time or they just want to buy a brand
new character so they can
go kill the whatever boss.
So they're willing to pent
spend $10 of real world money.
So someone needs to create a bank
for that and they create these,
these systems where they farm for gold
and they do it in a bunch of games to do
well.
The Warcraft they do in Diablo pretty
much any game that has a currency online.
There's a secondary marketplace where
people are grinding through the game,
doing repetitive things that are known
to give you a lot of that currency so
they can sell it back on the market
low and there's entire warehouses,
cyber cafes, you name it. Full operations
where people are employed to just click,
click,
click through any given game
to get virtual currency so
they can sell it back to
people that are and inflate it slightly
and played it for our way to show where
there was a couple that had a child and
they were both addicted to some game.
Oh and remember what the game was.
But it was one of the saddest things
in the world to watch this couple like
argue over who has to watch the kid
while they're playing their fucking game.
Their debt. Sheldon had died. Yeah.
Cause parents neglected down
playing starcraft or world
of Warcraft. Yeah, it's,
it's so frightening.
Yeah.
Well what they need to do is give the
kid an iPad so they can farm along with
Mommy and daddy's wasted process.
Like get that kid working.
It's so bizarre though. The pull is
so strong that it's really like it.
It's just like a drug. You could
call it a drug. Absolutely.
The addictions to video games are very
drug like any addiction to anything.
I mean you can,
people will find it in a way to be
addicted to whatever it is they want to be
addicted to and it's just as bad,
just as deadly,
just as caustic as anything else.
Funny what a weird animal we are,
where we can get addicted to doing things,
not just like not just sensations
that are caused by drugs,
but we can get addicted to doing thing.
Creatures of habit like I,
how much of your life is on autopilot?
I mean you lead a pretty diverse life
where you're doing different things at
different times, but the essential
is of your life. Like some,
some people will tell you that 80% of
like a relationship in life is autopilot.
That you're really only living 20% of
any given like longterm relationship
because you established such patterns
with yourself and with your job and with
your loved ones that
that Shit's on autopilot.
You're really only commanding 20% at
any given time when you decide to do
something out of the norm. That was,
that was a stat that was told to me,
and I kind of believe it.
I don't know if 80 is right,
but how much of your life is actually kind
of on autopilot if you think about it?
Yeah.
Well,
I think for a lot of folks it's the
easiest way to get through the day too.
If you're doing the commute every day,
hour and a half to the office,
you know some people,
it's really an hour in the morning.
Every morning just stuck,
stuck every day for an hour.
Some people commute four to six
hours to come in from long island.
Do you ever see that that hall coming
in from Long Island to Manhattan?
Holy Shit, I did that once at nine
o'clock in the morning and I was like,
this can't be real. This is no way.
This is real. You make everybody stop.
No wonder why this sucks and the
whole thing of tolls. By the way,
what a fuck?
What a fuck tolls are
paid to have this bridge installed and
now we're going to charge you every time
you drive on it
off the bridge.
But we kind of like you paying us every
week and we're pretty sure you're just
going to keep doing it.
So toll,
and that's one of the reasons
why Manhattan's traffic,
it's so fucking brutal as you're paying
tolls all over the place tolls to get in
from long island,
it's toll from Jersey.
There's this fucking totals
all over to me and it's just,
and they're like 10 bucks, right? Some
of them. Yeah. So we had like 10 bucks,
nine bucks, 10 bucks to do,
go over on my country bridge.
That is corruption of bridge that fuse
paid for it already paid. That's the,
you paid for it as well. Like
yes, it's already paid for.
You paid for it half the time.
As a tax payer,
it's a great way to generate revenue.
Right?
Isn't that a funny way of saying
it should be okay to rip you off,
rip you off and fuck up
traffic for everybody because
we will have more cutting
money and it's,
I like it.
The Tsa,
like we paid,
we've paid billions if not trillions of
dollars for this institution to erode
our own freedoms to grope us.
We paid for the privilege of longer
lines and radiation. That's insane.
And now I'm, well they did a
couple of pilot programs to like,
it was basically like a fast
lane through the Tsa Shit,
but she had to sign up and
some of them you had to pay.
So we had to pay for the institution
which degrades us and slows us down and we
can pay extra to bypass
it in a quicker way.
Well they need need to find out that
you're not a creep that's there.
Their re justification.
That's the justification.
Do a background check
on you and go well Kev,
a prayer or you've been in a federal
penitentiary seven times for selling
crystal meth.
We want to make sure you can still fly
southwest crystal meth in your underwear
though.
You've got weird baggies that show up
on our scans taped to your ball sack.
You want to explain,
sir?
First of all, those are feed. I eat
through my asshole. It's like a horse.
I feed it apples before every flight.
I learned about it from Brian
having a hand, having black math
taped to your balls. There's no,
you could say,
wait
a minute, we're the fuck.
How'd that get there?
This is someone else had to this bag, sir.
There's no fucking way that was there,
man. I can't even believe this
is real. What's going on, man?
Do you guys do something to me? I always
love that unconscious when it's like, oh,
we found this crack
pipe in your glove box.
Although I don't even know what that is.
It's got your initials on it.
Well that's, that's a coincidence.
That's not even, yeah man. It's Jr.
There's a lot of jail,
a whole lot of them Jr Roblin.
How would it you say your name? That's
the meth addict cousin of JK Rowling.
That one? Yeah. Harry Potter
didn't have any magic.
She was just tripping on trucker math
truck or there's a big sign in Santa
Monica Boulevard in Hollywood. I was, um,
I was driving down Santa Monica and
there's a huge billboard that says,
do you have a problem with meth?
And it just shows a guy,
like a regular guy, just his
face, like, Oh shit, I'm on math.
And I'm looking at, I'm like, wow,
how many people are on method?
They need to have a bill burri and
there's that billboard going to help you.
If you're on math, you're not
going to look up and go, oh my God,
I'm the billboard guy. I
should really stop this here.
Call this number, call this is my
room. And then when I got to do it,
I'll give you money.
No watching it.
You get me off math watching pieces of
your own face fall off at like a public
restroom mirror that's cracked.
It smells like urine when you look at
that and go, this met things. All right,
but oh my God, I'm on a billboard
now. I need to stop this.
Does anybody do research before
they do, man and go, wow.
Okay.
It looks like this is super addictive
and completely fucks your life up,
but I do want to get high.
Is there an Erowid for math?
Is there like a first time, some
difficult experience? Center is,
Arrowhead is awesome.
erowid.org is awesome for any,
any experiences you've had
that uh, even that, what,
whatever the fuck the actual
chemical is for bath salts. You know,
what is it an MDM? A UCB?
I think as well there's,
there's so many of them that had been
classified as bath salts or plant food
that it's hard to narrow it
down. It's, is that what it is?
I was saying that the other day,
but I wasn't sure.
There's a bunch of different
chemicals and they can eat.
It's not like it's one unit. Not at
all. All this pass. All right. Yeah.
Anything that will cause somebody to
eat somebody else's face is now a bath.
So even though it really was said that
it was pot, pot, he was high on pot.
You just had mad munchies. Man, that
guy was fucking unstable. That's it.
And that doesn't make for a
flashy news report, but well,
imagine if Paul really did do that to him.
That pop would be worth millions.
Like, listen, I know that dude eight,
that dude's face, but I wouldn't do that.
I want to know what that fucking wolverine
pies like you imagine a pop mean,
maybe, maybe make a fucking idiot,
eat a guy's face, but I'm, I'm,
I'm 100% fucking sure that there's not
a drug in the world that you could give
me that would change my mind about
eating the dude's face. You know,
there's only so high that you can get
and still be conscious like Jesus Christ,
you're weak, bitch. You didn't fight
off the urge at all. But just society,
that guy's face,
if they've,
I mean there's drugs that could turn
that guy's face into a candy bar or
something that's equally as delicious.
Sure.
I think when candy bars started screaming,
don't eat my face, it's me. Mark.
They're not saying that.
They're saying it feels like
you're hugging me with your tongue.
That's what they say when you're tripping.
All the guys screaming to his
eyeballs out. I think you're silly.
It's a Unicorn giggling like no way could
be so high that you would attribute it
so high that I thought it was a molecule
and in the cushion of my own couch and
I was swimming through my couch cushions.
Yeah. I thought my hands were dying.
We're just closing your
eyes and fantasizing.
You weren't involved in a life or death
struggle with a guy's face in your team.
But I also wasn't snorting bath salts
or taking this crazy sativa spot.
Yeah. I don't know about
that. Maybe just got stable.
Well Bitch of pot was legal.
You wouldn't have that kind of pot.
Nobody would want it to do you.
Did you have you used arrowhead to
figure out something like you're going to
take and how it's gonna Affect you
or to do research on chemicals?
Cause it's the only reason I've ever
tried anything in my life. Yeah.
It's very well documented. Yeah. It's,
I mean there's so many different
substances you could research there too.
It Shit. You would never even think
of morning glory seeds and you know,
San Pedro Cactus and you know how people
have prep prepared it and I don't know
how the fuck they get away with
it, but it's amazing. It's amazing.
A website and even for documenting things
that are, that are still legal. Yeah.
I wonder if the owner of that website,
just shitting bricks every
day just lives in Harlem,
then maybe they live somewhere
liberal or you can get away with more.
It's just so we're so, so gross. How
fucking stomped down we are here,
especially in the idea of drugs.
You know,
the idea of you volunteering to do
something to your body and that being a
possibility. Just that thought
of you making that decision.
It's a possibility of you getting caught
in the process of it and locked in a
cage for a long fucking time,
depending on what different thing you
decided that you're going to ingest and
what color you are as well.
What's your economic status?
So really it's disgusting. It's
so systematic. Fucking disgusting.
Embarrassing,
stupid.
In a world where you can go to cvs,
do you have it's slave labor.
It's legalized slave labor and especially
because the institutions are now
privatized and it's such a big industry
that lobbies like it's, it's privatized,
it's slavery, it's all go down
that cvs or any drugstore,
and I shouldn't say that,
uh,
any drug drugstore aisle that has one of
those little mini supermarket type drug
stores, you know what I
mean? Will they have like a,
like a little freezer section where they
sell ice cream and things and then they
have an alcohol lane and it's
a lie dude of hard core shit.
And any one of those bottles, you drank
the whole thing. You're dead, you're dead,
you're dead, you're dead, you're dead,
you're dead. People have done it.
We've done it all the time.
People would die.
People die of alcohol
poisoning all the time.
It's not as many as people
die from probably drunk
driving accidents. I mean, I,
that's probably,
but it's still alcohol related.
Alcohol related did death of just drinking
yourself to death. That's super possible.
You know, people do that all the time.
It's ridiculously easy to do.
So you just go to a store and it's
right there and pod is illegal.
But people are having these conversations
and maybe it's only because I'm
choosing to dial into the kind of
people that have these conversations,
but like how long is it going to take?
How many people have to have conversations
like this before there's actual
change.
I people are crazy people with money.
There's a lot of people that don't
believe in drugs take like Xanax. No.
Things like that. Yeah.
They'll take Sativex.
They'll take the the chemical
version of a sativa drug,
but they will not take the, the one that
the government has told them is illegal.
Yeah. I know a lady who takes Xanax and
she won't let her husband smoked pot.
She doesn't want her husband doing drugs.
The houses pitches on Salix every night.
It's Hilarious, man. It's hilarious.
They just puppet so maybe so
do we need to lobby them to,
to have that become illegal
as well because deaths
happened on that and who will
abuse it? Nope. I think you should be
able to take Xanax all day. Exactly.
You enjoy it. Dot. Marrero,
joy, Xanax. He takes Xanax every
day and he loves it. And I love dom.
And if that's what makes him happy,
better living through chemicals, go
40 men, he'd given him Xanax. Yeah.
Never say that someone should
not be able to do something.
It's just the things that
become obvious like math.
Does anybody have a good math
story? I mean, does anybody,
it's not a great one to
have my shit together,
but fucking I got on math and
let me tell you something, dude.
I really looked at my whole world with
clarity and purpose and I threw out all
the negative people in my
life and I started running.
Good morning.
No,
it leads to you in your basement with
chemicals like bins of chemicals and
fucking break fluid in a friend's bathtub.
You're running outside,
coughing up blood.
You've got bloodshot eyes and
you know you're out of your mind.
But if you happen to cross one of them
billboards, you will turn your life around
by 1500 boxes of cold serum.
Listen, I get really bad
allergies. Uh, listen,
I'm going to need 400 boxes
of sudafed if that's cool. No,
you don't look sketchy dude.
You bring your own brown box
to cvs. Excuse me, sir. You're,
you're scratching your own neck off.
Could you just be careful,
there's a lot of neck
under your fingernails,
bullying, like rural Texas where
they're just making crazy meth labs.
How many people have in the past like
walked into a drugstore and just Poland
enough to where I have to show my id if
I want some Claritin because I'm feeling
a little stuffy enough
people have done that.
I have to prove that I'm not going to
make a meth with an over the counter
product.
You,
your id not amazing. And
there's an amazing that that's
the drug you hear about.
Like one of my wife's friends just talking
about the small town where she lives
in Seattle.
And uh,
you go to this website where they
like talk about the town, you know,
like there's websites for every town,
like message boards. What do you,
what do you think about this area?
All anyone says,
and any of these rural places is math.
It'd be great if we didn't have
so much fucking meth. I mean,
there's meth all over the place
and keep away from the math people.
Like if you go into
small areas like small,
shitty, you know, low income
communities, boom, you got meth. Yeah,
it's cheapest, easiest. There you go.
But it's amazing how bad it sucks.
It's an epidemic.
It's amazing how bad it's up.
You mentioned that they focused all their
time on just math because there's no
positive math reasons and
stiff like fucking with all
these marijuana and people
just spin those that resource
to go just after math.
Yeah. Here's the difference. You ever
watch a Cheech and Chong movie? Yeah,
of course you did. Right? Right. Now,
have you ever watched an episode of
breaking bad? Yeah. Now we're in,
which show is someone more likely to
get fucking shot in the face, right?
The breaking bad that you
deal with meth people,
you deal with violence and craziness.
If you show up at some, you know,
pot place that's a dispensary it cannabis
care dispensary and you come on real
guns blazing with bulletproof vests on,
you know you're not going to get fragged.
You know you're,
you're right.
You're going to trip over someone doing
yoga and eating Keenwa did you see that
shit in Long Beach where the cops are
stepping on the dude when he was stepping,
stepping on his neck when he was down
and then busting the security camera
really like there's like you could make,
I hate there's, it's totally illegal.
I'd like to believe we live
in a society where, Oh,
you know like video was supposed to
release everything and end every ounce of
controversy and look there's proof,
here's the videotape and all it has done
is lead to arguments over context and
how interpretation of
those videos I disagreed.
There has definitely been a lot of
arguments but God damn is it fixed a lot.
It's brought a lot to light and you
know, just like this, I totally get that,
but it's,
I'm just shocked at the amount of that
analyst analyzing that can go on when it
gets in the way. Like some
people were saying, well look,
the guy was probably trying
to resist and pull back,
which is why it looks like he is.
That's why he stepped on his neck.
He was just in the thing. How do you
justify breaking the security camera?
There's no justification
for that whatsoever.
That young man wasn't resisting at all
and he didn't do anything and it was kind
of creepy and I don't want to
bring race into it, but I have to,
when a white guy steps on
the neck of a down black man,
you know though that that's like what,
first of all, he did it to my son.
I'd beat your ass. Right,
right. You Fat. Fuck,
you're just stepping on some
kid's neck for what? Because,
because that's your job today.
That's not,
that's nothing in your job
description is John. This is shit.
You're not in threatened by this
person any way, shape or form. You,
you might as well be walking into
a fucking cigarette store. It's no,
it's no different. You know, and
that jackbooted thug behavior.
There's no way that should
ever be tolerated by any
person who's a member of the
police force because the
police is supposed to be us.
It shouldn't be US versus them.
It shouldn't be. It should be.
The cops should be thinking about their
job is to protect their community.
That's what it really
should be to observe.
The law is to protect their community.
When they start doing shit like that,
you're not protected enough and you
fake piece of shit. You're just being a,
you're not
in danger. You know that side of criminal,
that's some kid who's a volunteer.
He wasn't even getting paid.
He was trying to figure out how to,
how the business worked and you know,
he's getting out of college
fucking Douche bags,
food to his neck. Stepdaughter man,
he stepped on him when he was down,
stepped on his back and then his neck
just decided to step on him like he could
do whatever the fuck you want it to
him. He was his, there will be an hour,
there will be an equally as loud chorus
saying that man was a working in a drug
operation and he was clearly in a,
in a criminal and it's their
job to squash down those types.
I bet that fact I didn't train.
I bet that guy that walked in,
that guy's neck and back
never trained in his life.
I bet he's never been humbled in a gym,
but he's never had a tap out.
I bet he's never done rounds.
You fat fuck dummy.
Yeah.
Or maybe he was picked on all his life
and that's why he decided to grab a badge
and a belt. I mean, it
could be probably not.
Probably just didn't have a lot
of options. So fucking stupid.
It's so stupid. It's such a
gross thing. That guy should,
he should either look sincerely apologize
and do something about it or he should
be fired. There's no way you shouldn't
be a cop. But that kind of attitude.
And it's crazy.
My brother's a cop,
so I get a crazy amount of perspective
from him on it. And, and, uh, you know,
and I'd like to believe he's one of
the great ones. Not a good one like,
but there's no,
there's no justifying that there's no,
there's no making that situation in
that video. Right. There's just none.
I support cops 100% of them.
I always do.
I think it's a really fucking hard job
and I think they're under pressure all
the time and they're asked to perform in
these crazy situations and abide by the
law when their own life is in
danger because of their job,
their own life is in danger. I'm a big
supporter cops, but I think two things.
First of all,
I think they don't get paid enough.
I think it should be a much
more difficult job to get.
It should be a prestigious job.
We should respect them.
They should be an honored part
of our community. We should,
we should look at them like what
they are though. They're heroes.
That's what they should be.
But instead they're not paid enough.
They're treated like shit.
They're,
they're treated like shit in the media
that treated like shit by people.
And so they develop an attitude and
US versus them attitude. And you know,
it's just an unfortunate
part of psychology.
Teachers develop that attitude as well.
There's a lot of teachers out there that
started with no noble aspirations until
they realize what $35,000
a year actually pays for.
And after awhile they get angry.
They get bummed out about it.
I think there should be positions in
our society that are revered and being a
police officers, one of them, and being
a teacher is also one of them. You know,
you can be hippy all you want
man, but guess what? Every people,
everybody doesn't play by the
fucking rules and you need cops,
you need cops and you need
guns, period. These, you know,
there's no way you're going to keep
bad people out of the, you know,
out of the system unless you have cops.
They should be an honored,
respected part of our society.
So when they see something like this,
they should fucking do something
clearly. It shouldn't be that
thin blue line cover up here,
suspended with pay and we're
going to review and it's bullshit.
They should be out. Right? They should
be more outraged about it than we say.
It's a current mood.
Maybe you had a shit day.
Maybe the kid said something to them
stupid, but you shouldn't do that, man.
You shouldn't do that. They should
because you shouldn't be there.
Anybody who's going to write a dispensary
should be forced to smoke a joint
first just because we tell
you if you're nice and stone,
we're not going to step on a dude's neck.
You're going to be like,
that's a great line here.
It's so true, right?
It's so wrong.
It's such an easy color too.
It's really embarrassing and most of
the cops, Garrett guarantee you they're,
they're not wanting to do this.
No, this is upper management.
Whoever the fuck is in charge of
making these decisions, a numbers, man,
it's all numbers, numbers,
numbers, numbers. Get your rest up,
get your quota and make sure people
are going to jail because we built more
jails and we need to fill the jails.
It's all numbers
incredible that we try to call
ourselves a free country. How dare we.
Yeah.
I mean look fucking subject to this free
enough to be able to say this in a room
at this time on the Internet,
like we got that amount of freedom.
That's really it.
Thank [inaudible] we can't do,
you can't have a free country
that makes as much money as we do.
You really can't because the only way
you can make as much money as we do as a
team, as a whole, as a country.
It's like you kind of fucking dominate
all the parts of the world that have all
the good shit. And if you don't get the
good shit from them, you know, like what?
How, how are you gonna how
are you going to run things?
You gotta you gotta you
gotta run things span.
We've got to have a lot of fucking
fossil fuels. We've got to have law.
It's almost like you can't be like really
cool and run a country like America.
It's like it would never
happen if everybody wants to
hang out with the cool guy.
They went home with a guy who
has to lithium if we want them,
they want to make some bad rejected
to anybody, to any, any, you know,
any negativity at all.
There was none of the,
none of the negativity associated
with our law enforcement.
None of the negativity
that you saw in that video.
None of the negativity when it comes
to siding with alcohol over, you know,
natural drugs, none of that.
If you took away all of that,
then you know,
I gotta be honest. I, my,
my asshole post puckered so tight as
those police sirens behind me lie,
they started crying. I was like, fuck,
they zeroed in on our Ip address and I'm
gonna have to stand up and ask if I'm
being detained and then
going to get maced and fuck.
I feel like getting a speed ticket is
going to turn into an occupy protest for
me. Every time I hear a
siren, it's like tragic.
It gets worse and it should
have gotten better. Yes,
we should have figured out
a way to make it better,
but instead with the age of information,
it seems like the tightening down,
it's like being coming
more and more absurd.
Just wait till there's a UAV is flying
into this room information with a camera
in your face.
Just letting them know that
they're listening cause
you've triggered the keyword
sativa. Hello. That's all
weird. It's going to happen.
Lord has already made commitments
to putting drones everywhere.
I think there there's,
and I'm blanking on the gentlemen,
there was a senator who's trying to get
legislation passed to make it illegal
for drones to be used to surveil
citizens without a warrant.
And that is exactly the kind of
protections we need to go for. Yeah,
but you really, you're going to have
stealth drones. Is it going to bugs?
They're going to have fake bugs the ball,
if they certainly got them now,
like if you believe in smart dust,
you could have stepped in something
that relayed your location in certain
keywords
possible to run an empire
and do it while being nice.
You're doing it is if you're doing it,
you don't want to screw the well On.
It is a supplement company.
It's very, it's a simple,
it's way more now and in five years
it's the empire. It's the cult.
I'm signing up and call Devonna.
I'm on it. Get on it. Yeah.
Is it possible to run America and be like,
and not have jackbooted
thugs raid dispensary's and
not have privatized prisons
and not have ridiculous
checkpoints and you know,
and is it possible to do that?
I don't. I think it is. I mean, I think,
I think you can still manipulate markets
the way that they do and I think it
could still still allow
them that can do that,
but give us enough freedom to where I
don't have to have my balls, you know,
fond or the fly to Vegas or not
go through a police check minor,
let me smoke my pot like you can,
you can manipulate the whole Libor
scandal that is beyond me right now.
The London interbank offering rate.
It's like it,
it dwarfs our little scandal
that we had here in what,
2008 2006 what is their scandal?
So their scandal is,
it's a little tangential to the
notion of running the country,
but so they're scandal
essentially boils down to a,
Barclays was the biggest, they have all
these emails and stuff. They, the, the,
the interbank offering rate is the
percentage at which banks will lend each
other money, lend each other
money. Right. And it's,
there's trillions of dollars in the
market that is indexed against that rate.
Your home loan is probably indexed
against it at some point. Right.
But tons of markets trade on it.
And to get that number,
the banks call two guys and
they report, yeah, we're,
we're lending money at the 4.3 today.
Great.
All the banks call in and there's like
an index of 20 of those numbers that are
averaged out from all the banks. And what
they did is they manipulated that rate.
They colluded. They called each other.
They would email each other and say,
we need the Libor index number to go up
by like a quarter of a percentage point.
So they would all report numbers that
were lower or higher than what they were
lending money to each other
on. It's convoluted. I know,
but what it would do is it in a day they
could bet against the rate, uh, the, the,
the Libor number going up or going
down so they can place bets on that,
manipulate it themselves and in a day
make millions upon millions of dollars
just by manipulating this and with every
manipulation your mortgage might go up,
your credit score could go down.
Like it can affect so many things
internationally. It's been for years.
How long did they do this?
It's been a,
there's emails that show there's been
going on for like 12 to 15 years,
but there's some people that are saying
it might have been going on in the early
nineties and it was a total honor
system reporting this number.
There's no transparency.
So all these banks got together and said,
it'd be like they just decided
we're all going to stay rich. Yeah,
yeah.
We're going to artificially inflate and
deflate this number to manipulate the
market to fuck with you,
but it's going to give us millions and
millions and millions of dollars and
that's what they've been doing for years.
That's when it's out in the open.
And yet, I mean, Barclays
got a slap on the wrist.
They're like a hundred million dollar
fine or three in a million dollar fine.
That's nothing in comparison
to what they made.
That's the problem with
punishments of these crimes.
You talk about that guy
in that dispensary is
probably going to go to jail
for six months. Right. And
get his next stepped on.
These guys pay $300 million for making
potentially trillions of dollars over the
course of 15 years and no one does.
Does any jail time or anything when,
whenever there's big money, man,
there's, there's big craziness now you
know about this money mo problems or drew
situation or doctor drew,
uh, became a part of, uh,
an investigation because
they, who was it that, uh,
doctor [inaudible] doctor
drew [inaudible] settlement.
What was the giant pharmaceutical
settlement that just happened was several
billion dollars. Was it Yasmin?
Whatever, whatever it was.
Doctor drew apparently was involved.
Dr Drew was recommending certain drugs
that they were asking him to recommend
and they give him, they gave
him $200,000, a $279,000,
allegedly some, some somewhere in that
range. Crazy to most doctors anyways.
People, doctors are incentivized to
sell certain drugs over other drugs.
Pharmaceutical companies do that all
the time or send them on retreats. Yeah.
But when you're a guy who's on TV,
like recommend treatments and stuff and
you're getting paid to recommend those
treatments. Alley. Wow.
That's a crazy blurry area.
Cause it seems to me like they paid you
to say some things you might not have
said he's going to say.
I wouldn't have said it if I didn't
believe in the product and I, you know,
I didn't believe in any of that. Money
did not affect my opinion whatsoever.
It didn't sway me one way,
but that's tragic because I want to
believe like Dr drew was one of those guys
that he's not supposed
to have any scandal.
He was supposed to be the one good guy.
Right. He was supposed to be the good guy.
As long as his penis works well, it's
very unlikely that he keeps it together.
He's a good guy, man. He really is. I've
loved him. Every time I met him I be like,
I want to believe you're real.
I want to believe in your magic.
Don't be a David Blaine on me.
Well,
his stance on marijuana is always were
pretty silly. Yeah, we are. We are.
We talked about it so much yesterday
that we can't really go on.
We had Tommy Chong on the podcast
yesterday. Oh yeah, of course.
Was massive amounts of weed talk shit.
The question Joe,
when he was talking about a heroin,
did you think in your head, wow,
that's really good. T tail and you know
like it's like we said he didn't do it.
It was really odd. Yeah. Chung or
doctor drew, Tommy, Tommy Chong.
I saw doctor drew tying off in a bathroom
and you read it. If doctor drew said,
listen, I shouldn't be talking shit about
these drugs and until I do the mall,
so it just goes on a show and that's his.
No doctor Juke gets high.
See if doctor drew is the same guy after
a month of Iowasca Ibogaine eating pot
brownies and mushroom Dr Dress
third eye every five days.
Dr Drew would go on a cleansing ritual
and eat nothing so much better than like
supersize me 30 days. DMT
and Kale. Good luck Dr drew.
We'll see you on the
outside every five days.
He does a new trip and we do
a whole season of this and in,
in between he's doing yoga, he's eating
really healthy. It's a $2 CPM right there.
Definitely good show.
It'd be awesome.
Could you imagine if you
could get a doctor drew to
do all nonlethal psychedelic
drugs if he agreed to it and he
has to do with the octomom. Oh,
now you fucked up to show that sweet,
sweet, sweet, sweet. You can do that.
Can you imagine the octomom
like examining, did you guys,
did you guys watch your porn? I did.
She had some nice and tight pussy.
It was really, I didn't watch it. She
couldn't, I didn't had no desire to.
She either guide it really fixed,
you know,
or the babies came out that
well but didn't she have
like a ton about other kids
are ready so none of her kids,
I guess that's the whole thing
just makes me incredibly sad.
Tentacle train rape from Japan.
No problem.
But I don't want to see the Octomom
Vagina tag Taggle train ray ban and the
archive. That's like telling
me Santa is not real. Fuck you.
How dare you do this to me. I
mean it is real. That's real.
And that background casting couch is
real as well. All that Shit's real.
When I say it's real, it's not real.
Rather. I mean it's magic. It's real.
It exists. It's fucking,
thank you for your imagined.
If that really became something you,
you really wanted to actually be next to
like if there was a real giant octopus
thing that could fuck women and
you would watch the whole thing,
I would purposely go to Shibuya and
take the yama know Tay Line in the hopes
that I would see that tentacled monster.
Yup.
While it was just school girls line up
on a bridge hoping the octopus chooses
them weeping softly
with pixelated genitals.
There was a spot in the world where there
was an octopus and it had like a hand
of Dolos and it would just pick people
up and fuck them in front of everybody.
It turns out that's what the law, that's
what the lochness monster really is.
Just a bunch of Dick arms under the
sea and anybody that happens to be
snorkeling on by picks up
Chapman and finger bags.
I mean that's,
it sounds like a Japanese amusement park.
It's no stranger than like lampreys that
cling to the bottom of sharks and you
know, eat the particles of
food that they leave behind.
You see the video of the clam today that
was surrounded by salt and was using
its clammy innards to move around
a table and it looks like a,
like a human tongue coming out of the, in
between. Have you, can you pull that up?
Do you have that?
It's so bizarre looking and that's
apparently how they navigate.
They don't have eyes or nose or anything,
so they use their tongue to sort of
navigate around and then we boil them or
steam those bitches, garlic on
them. The delicious, so good.
Gleaning clams. How great is it to
be on the top of the food chain?
It's pretty God damn good. That's
why I liked that show. Mountain men,
it reminds me that we're on the top
just waiting for this commercials.
You were sort of show true channel.
It's mount show mountain men.
That's my new favorite show and like
bearded prospect or types or three
different dudes living in the mountains.
One Dude lives in Alaska,
leaves his family, goes on a Bush
plane, flies three hours to his traps,
and he runs his traps for three months.
Just kills the kills little
animals and comes back.
I want to see the mountain
man wrestle. This guy. Oh,
this is the clam YTC this
madness that they put the,
they put the salt out so that it
would move along the salt. Some,
some people that said, yeah, that's
what it's doing. Uh, this ain't real.
You don't need this Israel? No,
I don't. Oh, I want to in this.
This is as real to me as those 10 o'clock.
I liking the way it's moving
around around the, uh,
if you're fleshlight did this, you'd
be all about it. I'm not buying this.
Look at that.
Yeah,
I dunno why, but what do you think
it's a viral for Internet explorer 10.
Like who's doing it? Has It?
Is it a who would do a viral,
like this is the optimum video.
There it is.
Clamps. So clams. They don't have to be
in the water. They don't have to like, no,
they do. They have to be in salt water.
But you have to breathe yet. I mean this,
this claim is dying. A slow death.
You're watching, you're watching.
It's last minutes.
How long do you think it takes?
This is by the way slash a clam snuff
porn is a viable internet fetish. Yeah,
it's pretty hot. Maybe it's real.
Maybe it's real. I it seems fake to me.
Does anybody on snuffy clients?
I don't. Maybe maybe it is real.
The salt on the table. It's
pretty real. Like, like,
like where that's the way it
looked it up and then it was good.
There wasn't a lot of pixelation
around like the opening of the clam,
which is a tell tale. Yeah.
This just seemed fake.
But what if that is true?
Bravo. Yeah. Love. Oh yeah,
absolutely. Isn't that crazy?
Now you can look at on video has gotten
so good and so easily edited that you
can look at anything you
go that's probably fake.
They're getting really close with
game of Thrones with the animals.
That's the first time like wolves looked
like real walls cause they usually look
so fake. It like blows the whole the
whole thing. You know, if the fake animal,
I can only dream wolves if I'm watching
game of Thrones because I fall asleep.
The moment that show comes on really
cannot do it for me. I don't know.
I just try, try. I was no snow. I got
all excited and I put it on. I was like,
here we go and I've heard of a doctor.
I've heard that from many people that I
heard is you just have to get through it.
Oh, you guys are crazy. But check this
out and hook the first episode show.
Look at this suck.
This is going to freak you out.
But if you guys haven't seen Black Mirror,
that's what you guys need to watch.
Look at this. It's going to freak
out. This is a clam. Okay. Oh Wow.
Oh that's real. Yeah, that's clammy
park cooler right there. That's a clam.
Moving around using this tongue to
push around. What a shit. Life Clams,
clams must've been really conti
in the last life, but who knows?
Maybe that clam is fucking loving life
right now. That's what we used to call,
like really country girls in Boston.
It was tough,
tough to call chicks cons back then.
Kinda had a lot more power back then.
If you call it the chicken cut back
in 1980 you were ready to fight.
You got to go to war. So they weren't
cones, they were clams. You know,
it's like whenever a girl was really,
because I grew up in New England,
so whenever a girl was really shitty
like Ah, she's a fucking clam.
It was always a clam and it just like
if you are claiming this life and came
back as a clam and need just some
shithead because you guys decided to start
calling him that too, which
is great because you have
no, I mean like the Hitler,
Hitler came back as a clam, you know, like
you don't even deserve to be a person.
But we also say happy as a clam. So
maybe they're really loving them. No,
they're just have a big watch,
stupid face.
So it looks like they're
smiling when they open up.
It looks like they're smiling.
Yeah, that's what it is.
It's not nearly as exciting.
I like to believe that that claim
is on a permanent trip right now.
Maybe they are.
Maybe they don't come until you eat them.
Let's let's go crazy.
That's the only
way to get us a clam off is to kill it.
It's the best
thing for them is to be eating.
That's when they're truly happy.
Until that happens, they
just, they try to find you.
The only way they can give
their love as if you eat them,
so you're a clam bake. Your clambake
is one wild orgy and you have no idea.
It's a mad,
mad come session.
Especially especially oysters.
They don't come until you eat them.
You've got to chew them and
eat them. That's what they
live and oysters, oysters.
What? I don't like the taste. The ocean.
We'll see things in a row real his last
time you'd done squads last time guys,
guys and arguments in a bar of Bro,
you don't like oysters range your face.
You laid off the power exercises.
Since I've seen you.
Have you backed off your clean completely
out of the completely out of the gym
rehabbing with Neon pink weights that
are like three pound nylon weights at the
gym. That sex just fucked my
shoulder up hardcore. Yeah.
Kevin a apparently got some dude to go a
little bit. You go too crazy. And I went,
I went in, so I got you. It was crazy.
I put on 12 pounds in three and a half,
four and a half weeks of like really
like really dedicated supplements in
everything, but just destroyed my
entire body over the course of that.
Well you have to take it slow. If you
haven't been lifting your whole life,
then all sudden you're,
you know,
you're doing fucking dead lifts and squats
and everything that he had a build up
to stuff like that. And you were you
doing? I'm always with a trainer,
like with somebody always showing you
how to do it right and make sure your
posture is
the majority of the time. Yes. But my
problem was that I would convince myself,
even if I was collapsing and passing out,
clearly I wasn't trying hard enough.
Like I could, I could squat more or do
more. So I got in my own head about it and
all that effort would have been so better
spent like in Jujitsu or something.
Now realize that now I am just trying
to get better so I can actually get into
something that's more of a martial art.
What is wrong with you?
This is just hurt my shoulder.
Like completely fucked
it up and you get an MRI.
They didn't do the MRI.
They did the x ray and said that was
good enough and I tried to explain,
I don't think you can see what you need
to see on it, but doing the Rehab I've,
I've gotten better.
Like I was just cleared to go back to
the gym but it's been a long fucking
process.
So you would just clear to be able to
work out again. Do you have no more pain?
Yeah, no. I mean I have well it at that
low weight high rep I'm, I'm pretty,
I'm pretty okay now
there's an awesome shoulder exercise.
Call the club bell and it's
not a heavyweight exercise.
I use 15 pound club
bells. I use them. Yeah.
And you know I've been doing it for a
while and there's a lot of great exercises
you can do with a 15 pack cause
it's a really weird offset thing.
Like there's dudes that use like 45
pounders. They're fucking savages.
These like giant wrestler do to
can do them with these huge ones.
I can't fuck with those but 15 pounds,
believe it or not.
It seems like a lot a tiny metal.
But is it explosive over the head
kind of or is it still on the plane
doing like these things called shield
casting and all it is is like controlled
movements of the shoulder and strengthens
your joints. It's very good for sure.
Like if I did that with a fishing weight
right now, I'd be okay. But anything,
anything above like a watch battery,
I'm going to destroy my shoulder just
cause it's that it's still that sensitive
to overhead movements. It sucks.
Sucks of it. Did you, you need
to get an Mri man. You might have had,
what is that guy doing? Is that some,
is that what you're talking about?
So something along those lines.
But there's something about the background
guy is that guy has a warming up before
he holds a woman against her will. Yeah.
That's all that is. It looks like a
worker at lax when he goes home at night.
You know like when the guys at flags
and playing times. This is one that I,
dude, that's one of the club bell
exercises that I do. He bells behind them.
The club's behind him. Yeah.
Those big ones are, that's
like strong man type shit.
That's like stuff that like,
you know, like uh, you know
like one of those Indian,
if you ever seen like
famous Indian wrestling,
like India is known like for uh,
developing like really powerful
men and wrestlers really back.
I've only seen like the lady boys that
do the pole dancing that run up the large
wooden huts. Lady Boys. Man, I
think that's pretty cool. And Rip.
I wouldn't say that to their face to
Joe, but to you, I just like lady boys.
I remember I went to Cirque du Soleil,
right?
Never felt more like a bitch,
man. I worked for the UFC,
but no one in the UFC has a
build like these fucking guys.
When you see dudes doing like a handstand
holding another dude up in the air
with one hand, you're like, wait a
minute, get the fuck outta here. Yeah,
well 500,000 gallons of water poured on
them from the ceiling and there's lights
in their eyes and they're just holding
it still costs and it's their third show
that night. Like insane. I
mean, they must be on roids.
There's no way.
There's no way he could do that and not
all be just like Cirque de Solei Jewson
pretty hardcore. You imagine
you're like, you know what,
I need drug testing in Cirque du Solei.
I don't want to watch some juice
heads holding each other up.
I want to know it's disingenuine to
the sport of acrobatic dancing. It's,
it's the whole thing.
It's wrong.
It's not supposed to be about
steroid and it's not fair.
You and I want to compete
on that level with them.
We want to be served to answers but
we don't want to have to juice. Yeah,
that's not fair.
I mean you have to hold a lot of
dudes over your head to get built.
Like those guys.
I'm not saying they juice cause you
can't get that big without choosing.
I had a friend who was a
total that natural bodybuilder
and he was fucking huge
and you would swear that this guy
did steroids. He never did anything.
It's not 100% natural,
just obsessed and worked out
like a maniac and was enormous.
But it is possible. Sure. It's just
really hard to do. It's super hard to do.
So most people assume, especially for
certain body types, certain body tops,
it's impossible.
You know like extreme ectomorphs he
ever met like really thin people with
incredibly thin faith,
thin hands.
Those folks have a really hard time
putting on weight and most of us are
combinations of an ectomorph and
endomorph you know, is a little bit of an,
you know,
a little bit of Meza more for sure were
slight combination of people who are
extreme ectomorphs like, man,
those people were, that's a tough,
it's tough to try to get strong.
Yeah,
yeah. I don't know. I've,
I feel like I wonder how much genetics
plays into my own ability to to go down
that path. You know, like, well for sure
you went too hard to quote clearly. Yeah,
clearly.
I mean I realize that this
was completely my error,
but I wonder dedicated doing it properly,
how much change you can actually,
you can actually,
you got to just cut to be healthy.
You got to make sure that a lot of sleep,
you've got to make sure
you do the power exercises,
but you've got to make sure before you
do any of that. Then you build a base.
Right now,
if people that have
10 years of playing quake world
competitively, it capture the flag.
I thought that was enough of a base to
get into the gym and going to beast mode,
but it wasn't quake one capture
the flight. I used to set up,
I used to set up a tub.
I don't know if I told you this before.
I used to set up a tub of
margarine next to my keyboard.
I would get a loaf of fresh French bread
on the way home and then it would get
instant mashed potatoes with gravy and
put that bowl next to it and so I would
be playing team fortress or you know,
wolf and Stein or doing whatever.
I would sit down, play, click,
click, click, break off bread,
dip it in the margarine.
Then dip that in the mashed
potatoes and gravy and eat that.
That was my dinner for weeks on end.
Every day. God, you ruined your body.
Oh Man. Bpay years, years,
years and years.
Did you notice a difference in your
body from that, from eating that?
Well,
I mean there was no different,
there was no nothing to compare it
to because I was always a chubby kid.
You know, like I was constantly eating
and internetting that was my life.
So now I have something to compare it to.
Now it's,
so now I want to swing it in
that other direction, which is,
so when you started to work out, did you
just immediately dive into it? Fuck yeah,
I got, it was, I was probably about
20, 21 years old when I was like,
I need to change this. I lost a
little bit of weight, but I was like,
I need to change this.
And so off of like three Google searches,
I created the ultimate uh,
ultimate workout regimen,
which was nothing but a small piece of
chicken and white rice for, you know,
three times a day and running a,
you know,
two to three miles in the morning and
two to three miles at night every single
day for about six weeks and
lost a shit ton of weight. Uh,
got dangerously thin, developed
a body image disorder, killed,
killed my knees from
running, running, running.
Did you have, did you kept saying the
girls, you think I'm fat, don't you?
What? No, I would say that to like
guys and chat rooms mostly. I'm like,
what you would you fuck me IRL?
Really Lol.
By the way, cut the show with the
lol is we need not really lol.
Oh No. Yeah, yeah. That's a movie. No
parking. Lol. But it's become a throwaway.
It's becoming a, okay. That was amusing.
Lol. But I'll go with her. Yeah,
like a hand needs to be the lol.
Like if you're really laughing out
loud fucking mean it. Yes. This is my,
this is my podium. I'm sorry. I don't
know. He didn't make the show a platform.
So you put together this,
this godawful routine.
So you just from youtube clips and from,
it was just like googling,
like literally like the how to get in
shape. How to lose weight. Thing is folks,
if you really want to join,
don't even join a gym. Okay.
You really want to work out, make
yourself work out at home, make yourself,
cause if you really want to work out,
you will fucking work out at home.
Make yourself work out
at home for one month.
And if after one month you're still doing
it, then waste your money on the gym.
Yup. Because how many people join
a fucking gym and then just never
and and if you join and try to quit,
they make it the most impossible process.
It's like trying to quit the army. Go,
fuck, you are locked for life a month.
A month.
Well you got to talk to Pat,
the supervisor who gives you a form to
fill out to mail to some place to get a
confirmation.
How about the creepiness
where they actually like the
take the money out of your,
your account every month we had a debit.
Yeah.
I usually can't easily canceled my gym
membership when my credit card expires.
That's what just happened to be
at la fitness. I was like, ah,
it's got like six months left. I'll
let it run out. It's going to be,
it's going to be quite a week's worth of
work to cancel it. I'll just let it go.
If you have a wall in your house, you
can get a workout. We've got the door.
You've got a gym. Well for, for
real if you, if you have a wall,
because I would say if it's the only
thing you need is you need to be able to
prop your feet up on something
so you can do handstand pushups.
Everything else you can do on the ground.
You can do pushups in the ground.
You can do tricep extensions. You could
do like a form of dips with a chair.
You know if you don't have a chair,
go fuck yourself.
Do there's chairs in the world.
You can find a bench.
If you can hear this podcast you can
find a wall and a bench out in the world.
Just be body weight squats. One of
them, one of the biggest exercise I do,
we've talked about it a bunch of times.
It's Hindu squats. I do 200 of them.
When I do my strength and conditioning
workout, it's fucking brutal man.
It's like I'm in pretty good shape.
I do Jujitsu on a regular basis
like kickbox on a regular basis.
I stay in shape.
I keep working out these 200 fucking
body weight squats kicked my ass like
almost nothing. It's like,
cause the first one is easy.
The second one is easy. You hit 10 no
problem. 20 I'm feeling it a little,
but I,
I can see the the finishing line and
then once you get around a hundred you're
like holy fuck where your knees are
buckling and shaking like a seismic
earthquake on the way down
because their muscles can't do it.
You've got a hundred ago,
hundred ago. Oh. But it's a,
it's an incredible workout for your legs.
My legs have never been stronger.
I feel like I'm on springs all the time.
Like when I do my kickboxing workouts,
I have much more power in my legs.
My ability to move. It seems like,
like a movies you're like,
I can get away from things.
It's like it's the real way to
strengthen your legs the real ways.
Not really like lifting giant
shit over and over again.
That's puts so much pressure on your bag.
Back joints,
the real way to strengthen your legs,
his body weight squats.
It's crazy how good that shit works. We
still like if you really want to get big,
but squats really do work. You know, any,
anything where you really load up on
heavyweights and the dead lifts and stuff
because even though body weight squats
will strengthen your legs and make your
legs a little bit bigger,
they're never going to get,
you're never going to get those
ridiculous powerlifter thought.
There was a moment where I thought, oh,
that's what I want to go for, or that's,
you know, that's, that's how lifter, yeah,
like I like the power lifting physique
and regimen because training in short
bursts like that was really easy for me.
Like I liked that notion of just give it
all for five reps and you're done kind
of thing.
But now I realize I just need to be
confident enough to leap over a puddle on
the way out of my car. Like I don't have
enough command of my body that I like.
I play Frisbee and I'm like,
I'm probably gonna Roll my ankle.
I got to be careful now guys.
Like it's that bad.
I went golfing and my
elbow hurt. Like, oh no.
Yeah. It's just the, you
know, you don't need to
maintenance alone.
I think it's,
it's so important to work out just to
keep everything moving and not atrophying.
Cause you see certain people get to a
certain age and like you look at them and
then you look at some Jack Lane type
character that just kept working out when
he was at same age. Look how
much more mobility. Yeah.
It's almost like you're investing in
making sure your car works cause they'll
give your card doesn't
work you fucking stranded.
Well if your body starts to shut out
when you're 40 or 50 or whatever that,
that a lot of that can be avoided.
And the way it could be avoid
is to make sure you keep it up,
keep it work and keep lifting weights.
Keep going to the gym, keep eating right,
keep working on your cardio. Just
that's the have to do it. It's not,
it's not an option.
Like for too many people it's like
I'd like to give the gym but gosh,
so the time it shit,
you shouldn't even be living your
life with that in consideration.
It should be a staple.
It should be a staple along with it.
I mean you want to be healthy.
I mean,
you should be able to do
whatever the fuck you want to do,
but if you want to be healthy,
you got to have your body healthy.
I really believe that.
I don't see how you can have like real
happiness with an imbalance body about
it's fucking up on.
Yeah,
wholeheartedly agree.
I mean,
I think the key in life for everything
is just balance, right? That's all it is.
So your, your physical, your
physical being and you're, you're,
it's with you every day. It's
your vehicle. It's your vessel.
So how can you be balanced
work and home life or whatever.
If you're not balancing the physical
portion of your bs going on hikes, smash,
you're just going on a hike.
You don't have to go to a gym.
I used to go hiking when
I lived in Colorado. Man,
fucking hikes will kick your ass,
man. Especially at altitude, you know,
you're walking up the side of a hill.
That's a, that's a real workout.
It's a nice cardiovascular workout.
You feel good when it's over.
Your body's designed to do it.
Years and years and years of programming,
you're hungry or some dudes love cutting
Woodman.
You know,
I remember George Foreman was the first
fighter that I ever saw that we would
cut wood as a part of his workouts
because back then when people were lifting
weights, it's like a lot of fighters
didn't lift weights back then. And like,
especially like in the 1980s like
nobody ever really lifted weights.
When Mike Tyson came along,
Mike Tyson had a crazy physique,
but when most people don't know it
was all chin ups and push ups and he,
he was just a thick dude,
a thick dude who was in impeccable
condition and he really wasn't like a big
weightlifter.
But then Evander Holyfield came along
and Evander Holyfield was the first guy
that show that there's benefits to
lifting weights because all those guys,
before then, they were
all trained in, you know,
they would do like a bodybuilding workout
and then they go to the gym and they
couldn't move their arms because they
were sore and they'd get beat up.
So the trainer would tell them, oh hey, I
had fucking away left and shut you down.
She go to your dad's rap and it's,
that's not what it is. Is the Guy Sore?
You know it's going to make you
faster for sure. We know that now
if you're used to throwing an
extra hundred pounds without arm,
when you're not throwing it
to get to go a little faster,
it's going to hit a little harder. But
the olden days, man, but splitting wood,
that's a brilliant,
I like,
I see the crossfit stuff where
they're pushing tut tires, uphills,
forming these higher workout pulled
trucks. He would pull a rather a jeep.
He would our jeep behind him.
He would push it and pull it.
It's strapped himself to thing
and nobody else was doing that.
Back then when George Foreman was
doing that, he was doing crazy shit.
I remember a braiding the fat
from the meat when you grill it.
That's the kind of crazy shit for him was
up to do that. I don't even know grill.
Well, I know his grill. Yeah. What I'm
saying. I don't think you use that,
but I'm saying that's how ingenious he is.
Man.
That dude made a ton of money off way
more than getting punched in the face.
Man made a lot more money off
of a plastic dorm, you know,
like chicken and steak cooker.
He was punched in the face.
Amazing human being.
Would he accomplish was very rare when
he was 36 years old after like he got
beat up by Muhammad Ali in Africa and
it was the most humiliating defeat.
It just, he wasn't the same after that
and he fought. He fought Ron Lyle is,
that would be fine if I can take a step
back. Was he expected to win at all? Oh,
he was. They thought
it was, this is fight.
The fight was such a one sided mismatch
and most people's eyes that hunter s
Thompson flew to Africa
and didn't go to the fight.
Instead he took acid
and war and Nixon mask.
It's swimming around in the pool and it
was a huge disaster for hunters career
because he was supposed to turn
this story into rolling stone.
Muhammad Ali winds up beating George
Foreman and he wasn't even there.
He started in the shallow,
he missed the entire fight.
So Ali just ran a class on it.
Like you could say, hey man,
can you guys give me a USB drive so I
could actually watch the fight and my job
and tell the story. He couldn't even
do that because there was nothing.
So hunter had,
there was a huge failure because he was
in Muhammad Ali fan and he didn't want
to watch Muhammad Ali get destroyed.
Even Muhammad Ali fans didn't want to
watch that fight because Ali was in the
twilight of his career.
He had taken those three years off and
really was never the same guy again.
He was never the same as when he was
before they took the title away from him.
When he came back,
he,
he became more of a guy would stand in
front of you and take punches until you
got tired, then be, you know, rope, a
dope strategy, which news on format.
And after foreman, after Frazier had
dropped him and Frazier beat him. And, uh,
the, uh, the first fight to sort
of unify the title after that,
most people thought that
Muhammad Ali was just,
he was just not quite as good as it used
to be and sort of a step down and he
was slowly starting to fade away.
So George Foreman beat the fucking
shit out of Joe Frazier. I mean,
it was a brutal Kao and was one of those
brutal chaos where he hit foreman or
foreman rather hit Frazier and picked
him up in the air with his punch.
She did like a little skip the superman
punch out star appears above his head.
Cool. Brian pulled it up because it's so
weird. But pull up form versus Frazier.
Kao It's, Oh, another run time ever.
No problem. Hey, don't worry about it.
This is a says the power's off.
Brian's this power thing.
This podcast is brought to you
by technology. There it goes.
Alright, it's charging
now. Anyway, he hit Frazier
and he hit him so fucking hard.
Is this the whole fight or just the chaos
dilemma?
Oh, the wolves are beating the
Pistons. That sucks. This was 1960 on.
I'd be surprised if we wanted to.
Now you got to watch how
hard for him and Pitsa.
Okay.
And Joe Frazier,
by the way,
tagged for him and a bunch of times
Joe Frazier is a bad motherfucker.
Yeah,
it's weird watching these guys as, yeah.
He needs to take him to the ground.
He's losing,
he's losing the standup game.
Right. You're right. But that gap
to Frazier is such a crazy style is
bobbing and weaving winging punches.
You know,
all I can think of is the damage that's
done with each little tap to the brain.
Oh yeah.
Here's one foreman starts landing on him.
Look at Harvey is, he
hits so hard, he hits you,
just changes everything.
He would wait to throw
his whole body into it.
There's so much power in his punches
and he was a good boxer to
a surprisingly good boxer.
Like the reason why like he
was able to land those punches.
He was very unorthodox
in the way he would box.
He was like push guys off a lot. See
how he's doing that? Just pawn and Matt,
he's pushing them away from me.
Don't get it inside and then he would,
he would plot at you with a jab,
but then when he knew that
you were going to be there,
that's when he would win the
big ones like right there.
See most of them were short punches.
Like his jab is a nice door, Jeff.
There's the uppercut. Oof.
But watch when he gets up,
foreman had ridiculous power, man.
Watch how hard he hit when he gets up.
He's literally going to go in the air.
Watch this shit. Ooh, look at this.
I saw him. I saw him go
for it right there. God,
he's winging punches
at him. Oh Nice. Jack.
Set up the whole body behind it.
Yeah. That jab is a fucking fence.
Posts they rented,
rented the body,
getting telephone pulled in the face and
that was his big weapon as he got older
to just slowly but surely just
chipping away at Joe Frazier.
It's like car accident gooeys
and the speed. So smart,
but the way he's boxing is so smart.
Just keeping them off of the jam.
I just see more than the hooks and
look at there's the shot. Oh my God,
that upper cut was bad and there's
boom, look at that one. Oh Jesus.
There went his first bike ride.
Oh, there. When his first date,
oh my God, there went his
ability to control his bowels.
That upper cut was incredible.
They're going to keep this fight going.
They didn't give a fuck in the
70s did you want to get up son?
Put up your dukes. That's
amazing. The watch this.
Oh, oh, that's it. Here we go.
Now to continues, dude,
are you kidding me? I mean,
how hard
is that guy hit
sweet prints. So coming out of this
fight, everybody thought, you know what?
This guy's going to kill him.
He's going to kill Ali.
Like what did he do to Frazier?
He did that to Joe Frazier.
That's what does that one round
or two rounds the first round,
I think as a first round.
So if he did that to Frazier,
what the fuck is he going to
do? He's going to steamroll
stands in front of guys.
He takes shots. He's got this rope, a dope
style, and he's three years coming back.
Okay. He wrote it up the fuck
out of George Foreman stopped.
Did you ever see the stoppage?
I'll pull that up to pull up an Aldi
chaos foreman cause it was beautiful.
It's one of the greatest moments
in the history of sports.
Nobody thought it was going to win.
Nobody thought I was getting.
When he goes to Africa, he's dancing and
yell and he's got the whole crowd going.
[inaudible] boom. By yet
telling him like Ali, kill him.
The whole crowd is saying Ali kill him.
Jesus,
he's got everybody convinced that George
Foreman is a fake and he's with the
white man. She's fucking,
he just, he tortured him,
he tortured them and then
when he got into the ring man,
he just fucking boxed him up, boxed
him up, moved around tired amount.
Then when he finally got,
I'm tired and he connected top dome and
another right hand and put form in a way,
and it was crazy. Nobody believed it.
Nobody believed people were going nuts.
People in America were fucking screaming
and jumping in the streets because he
foreman represented something really
scary, this big crazy black dude.
Or walked around with German shepherds.
This is the chaos. Was that
it right there? Yeah. Pull it,
pull it back so you can see it.
So for eight rounds,
he beat the shit out of Muhammad Ali.
Dude for eight rounds.
This is the end of the fight.
It looks like he's just
and arms out there that has done
the clean and then look at this.
There's the distance.
I love that music too. That's
fantastic. Where is blitz?
Is that from a Ali's documentary?
No, when we were kings.
This is a Bruce splits creation according
to the watermark on the youtube video.
Yeah. Oh, Bruce splits
creation. Thanks Bruce Bloods.
Bruce credits you fucking savage.
So that's why everybody was going crazy.
They didn't Tim.
Yeah, it was, uh, it was the
beginning of the end of Huna.
Rez Thompson's literary career.
He started kind of falling apart after
that and became crazier and crazier,
unfortunately. And you
said it, that was the,
that was sort of the beginning of the
end for four minutes. Well, yeah, yeah.
That was when foreman had
one more fight after that.
And I think he fought Ron Lyle.
I think that's what we fought.
But they had this crazy back and forth,
fucking crazy war and uh,
he got knocked down a couple of times
and just wasn't the same. George Foreman,
like I'll lead,
took it from him.
So then he retired and then he became
this priest and he became a preacher and
found God's word and got fat as fuck.
And then at 36 years of age,
I think you'd be not a
fighting for 10 years.
I think that's how long you've been out.
He just decides 300 plus pounds fat as
fuck decides is going to make a comeback.
And I remember reading about it and
being in a boxing fan going, oh wow,
he's going to make it come back. That's
crazy. Yeah. Good luck. That's all. I was,
come on George Foreman in the modern era.
He's a giant fat guy and then all of a
sudden he just like kept losing weight
and he kept beating people.
And then he got to Jerry coat,
uh, not cherry coat. Sia,
Gerry Cooney,
he got to Gerry Cooney and beat the
fucking shit out of Gerry Cooney.
Pull that up. Ryan pull Blah
George Foreman. Kaos Gerry Cooney.
I love Youtube. It's
amazing. It's so credible.
All on demand. Yeah. Edited and you can
get the dubstep remix of that fight.
Actually pulled that one up with
when George Foreman Kao Gerry Cooney,
I think he was in his forties.
I'm pretty sure he was in
his forties. And uh, he,
he was the oldest man to
win the heavyweight title.
He was 46 when he knocked
out Michael Moore and Michael
Moore was a fucking stud.
He was a really good boxer form and
hit him with one of those canned hams,
those giant fucking fists
of his, it's just a hard for
me to watch. Like I respect
boxing highlights when they're from the
time where MMA didn't exist because,
because now you know, you look
at it and go, okay, well that's,
that's impressive again,
because that was the sport and that was,
they were the best at it.
But nowadays,
like the boxing has completely lost
any ounce of appeal for me. Just has,
I prefer,
um,
quite honestly I prefer MMA to everything,
but I do like stand up fighting only.
I do still like that.
I prefer kickboxing. I like, I'm
sure you know what it's showtime.
Has He ever watch it? Showtime. They
just sold themselves to golden glory.
So now it's just called glory.
That's the, the, the new, uh, they,
they combined forces,
they bought them out.
Is it all like a k one or it's
just like be better than cable.
It's going to be the best
fighters. It's all the, cause.
Th Th the k one organization after a
while, stop paying people and they would,
they,
they had money problems for a while and
then a new company bought them out and
then they did a may show.
They did a show in May and people
didn't get paid from that either.
Not Everybody got paid
like the big guys got paid,
so it showtime and glory
decided to get together,
but most people in America don't even
know how fucking bad ass kickboxing is.
Like real boxing.
I mean,
we got used to that PKA karate shit
in the 80s which was quite honestly,
I mean it was a lot of fun. I enjoyed
it. There's a lot of very good fighters,
you know, that that came out of that,
you know, that actually, you know,
tennis Alexio and the guys
who are really good fighters.
But the style wasn't that exciting.
I mean, you'd make people,
they had to like kick like eight
times and around. Otherwise, you know,
they'd get penalized because most people,
it's just like sloppy box.
This is nothing like that. This is
incredibly technical point in time.
Yeah. Look at this. Gerry
Cooney and George Foreman,
I believe he's in his forties here.
Look at this.
Gerry Cooney had challenged for
the title at one point in time.
He fought Larry Holmes.
He was a murderous puncher,
knocked out Ken Norton and one of
the most vicious knockouts ever.
A ruthless Naca. He Could Bang
Matt's big fucking White Guy.
But George woman also open,
he opened a lot of people's eyes with,
oh well he could take Cooney's punches
to look at. Oh, look at that one too.
Boodle brewed. Oh God. Damn.
George Foreman was a bad motherfucker.
What a combination, man. Get up.
Go in Benjamin. He's getting
up. How tough is Gerry Cooney?
He's getting up after that. He's going to
keep going. Did she know you ain't okay?
Never been clocked like that. Look
at this. Look at this. Oh one side.
Just step in uppercut.
Brian, please rewind that.
Just rewind a second one. We won
the second part again. Oh, that was,
this is Gloria. So look at this upper cut.
Boom. He, he didn't need to follow up.
Even need the follow up. We just wanted
him to hit him. George Foreman, stepson,
left upper cuts him steps to it.
Right,
right and right. Handsome. He was a,
he was a really underrated boxer, man.
He said he, that guy was a, you know,
a really, really interesting fighter.
But Muhammad Ali, he took his
soul in Zaire. But how was
his ground game? Um, yeah,
his ground game was probably
about like James, Tony's.
That's so good. That's so good. You know,
they all could develop a ground game.
Anybody can develop this round game.
All you have to do is put it in the time.
It's a problem is when you
go there, you're going to
feel like a bitch. You know,
you just gotta be able to do that
because a lot of people have a distorted
perception of how well they could
defend themselves. And you know,
you get in there your role,
like I,
my friend Cade weighs 140
pounds and I'm not bullshitting.
He might wait one 45 he's very slight.
It's very thin,
but he's a black belt in
Jujitsu, you know, and I am,
I'm 50 pounds fucking heavier than him.
But if I roll with him,
I got to watch what I'm doing cause
he'll fucking slap a triangle. I mean,
I'll go unconscious. I mean that's just,
that's the reality of MMA as opposed to,
you know, to boxing is that, you
know, in, in, in a, in a boxing match,
the fact that you're not going to ever
see that he never going to see a guy slap
a triangle and a guy in the
middle of a fight, right?
And Oh shit, he locked it in.
You're missing half the
fun. You're, you're, you're,
you're only going to be able to hit guys.
It's great to hit guys.
I love watching a fight. We're two
dudes throw blows and there were,
right. But I just think it's, it's chess
versus checkers. Like, and I'm not,
I'm not downplaying the
nuance of the boxing game,
but there are so many more outcomes.
You have to factor in
every single millisecond.
You're in an Nma match with someone
versus a boxing. That is true.
Your button has to keep that in.
You never see the high level striking
in MMA that you see in like glory and k
one you don't see it.
You don't see it at that level.
They're just not as though
they're not as good.
And one of the reasons why they're not
as good is because they also have to
factor in take down attempts.
Right?
So they have to change their stance a
little bit and they have to there they
have to constantly be thinking
about like if they throw a kick,
they're going to get taken down
and they might lose the round.
The guy gets on top of 'em there might
not be able to submit them. There's some,
when you don't have to think
about any take downs, then do.
It can really shoot you.
Really the punchline and some of the
punching and kicking is so exciting and
kickboxing, man. See I,
that's my favorite shit to watch when
I watched dude's leg kicking dudes and
fucking flying knee and each other in the
face and dropping elbows on each other.
I mean it's so wild.
Like how good some of the best guys are.
It's just pure stand up and an MMA.
It's real hard to get to dudes that good
at standup who also have good ground
game. Right. You know,
it's cause usually when you get to a guy
like at Giorgio Petrosyan who's like a
multiple time world champion,
one of the best fighters in the world,
Georgia Petrosian is
a straight kick boxer.
That's all that guy does and he's the
fucking best and he fucks guys up that are
like really high level world champions,
figures out their game and you can't do
that if you're also taking Jujitsu class.
You can't do that if
you're also, you know, uh,
trying to put on weight because
there's a, you know, 175,
170 pound division and the next
way class has one 85 right?
So you got to figure out what the fuck
to do either dehydrate yourself or puts a
mass on. You don't have to do that.
And we kickboxing you just fight it,
whatever the fuck away class you are.
There's a lot of weight classes and
glory is that, that's a new organization.
It's both golden glory formed glory
and glory is a kickbox and organization
they've already had. I know they've
already had at least one show,
but fucking high level kickboxing to me
is like one of the most fun things to
watch.
Yeah.
Well I got to recommend something to
you. Actually. It's, it's Tangental,
but I just don't want to forget too.
I love it.
You've used the term
tangental twice as podcast,
which is more than I've ever used it
in life suite. It's a great words.
I love that word. It's
fantastic. I wouldn't mind,
I might use it in a, um, uh,
something I wrote,
but I would have to look it up to
make sure he's using it right. No,
I don't want to fuck it up.
No, you'll be all right.
Anytime, anytime you want to go off
on a tangent. I apologize and gentle.
What is the chant? Tangental points?
It's was just recommended to me recently.
It's a BBC,
like a mini series,
three 40 minute episodes called a black
mirror and it deals with the sort of
near futuristic societal issues that
will come about because of the ever
evolving pace of technology and how
it gets intrusive into our lives.
It's brilliantly shot, directed, edited.
It's one of the best things I've
seen in a long fucking time.
A black man called black mirror.
It's, there's three episodes and I,
I'm hesitant and reluctant to speak about
it any further because I don't want to
spoil anything like each. It's a BBC.
I think it was done for the BBC. No,
it was a,
it was like a three re tweeting it.
That's why I'm going to let to get three
up, three mini series or three episodes,
three mini series. I guess they're like
40 minute episodes. They're phenomenal.
I cannot recommend them enough.
I've been showing them to everybody
that it's beautiful. I haven't been,
I can't believe they
haven't aired over here yet.
I think they aired in India and the
UK and that was just stupid. It's,
it's beautiful. Um, I, that
is a gorgeous mirror as well.
That sat in mirror is phenomenal.
Look at the depth of that.
Why are you looking at a
mirror? I, it's what came up.
He was looking up, sat in black
cock. The moment I tight black,
the suggestions are cock mouth, glory
hole. It's weird. Brian's computer.
This suggests all these weird things I
was searching for Benihanas and it popped
up,
boot cocky right away.
BBC miniseries on future
technology recommended
by Kevin.
It's amazing. Well, I guess we can
kind of dip into one which was,
you know, the, the, the Google
glasses you've seen as likable glass.
So the notion of having every moment
recorded of all the time, all the time,
what that's going to lead to,
people have been like, oh,
it's going to lead to freedom
and democracy and whatever.
I never really gave much thought of it
in a, like the context of a relationship.
And a couple of gets in an
argument where someone says, well,
you said something a certain
way a little while ago.
I'm trying not to spoil things.
And the guy goes, oh, did
I, let's look at the tape.
And then they're both going
back and analyzing the argument,
which causes them to analyze other things
and it causes them to go, you know,
there's,
there's even the notion of,
of of children suing their
parents over decreased, uh,
like wages in the future because they
didn't show enough support during a tee
ball game or whatever
when they were younger.
Like the notion that that could resist,
it could exist in a near future because
of the pace of technology is mindblowing.
Yeah.
You imagine if you could sue your parents
cause they did a shit job of raising
you.
Like go back and show the evidence and
your father was millionaire bank dude and
just didn't spend any time you
exhibit 47 where you didn't love me.
Let's go through and here it is.
Let's show this is the first
time that I missed the party.
This is how he treated me. I was
too. Right. You can relate to that.
That's coming right. Has it has
absolutely happened. Yeah. This,
this whole thing is not going to,
it's not like it's going to stop this,
this intrusion,
this integration,
this symbiotic relationship
that we have with the machine.
Yeah, that's, that's fair. Like the,
the intrusion part is where like now most
people don't see it as an intrusion at
all.
They're happily adopting.
It seems like it. I think it's going
to be, the situation's going to be,
that's just what life is and it's
not going to be an intrusion.
It's just there's not going to be
privacy anymore. It's going to,
it's going to come to that.
Well, I think there'll be privacy for
those who can afford it. You know,
there's going to be a percentage of the,
of society that has enough money to hide
what they're doing or make what they're
doing legal and oppress others. I want to
be friends with them. Yeah. By the way,
that we're all good. We're rapidly
climbing that mountain man. Your clothes
need to get join a country club or
something and they start a super pac.
So they like me and they'll tell me when
they were about to make shit go down.
Don't go to the twin towers
were playing golf. By the way,
that black mirror is a channel for not
BBC. My apologies. It's still brilliant.
Oh, it's channel four. Yeah.
Oh, you son of a bitch.
Where you that specific with
it? Oh, I just, you know,
just tell people to being black mirror
and then they'll laugh at you for using
bang. That's true. Fucking
spider man or man or man,
did you like that movie? I had
to tweet it. I was like that.
That really ruined my suspension
of disbelief. Like here,
I'm supposed to believe this kid is like
crazy inventor and he lives in a world
where people can hand 3d vector models
to each other and there's crazy high end
technology everywhere
and yet he's using bing.
I don't think sending that don't even
get me started. And then that tablet,
what do you think about that tablet,
that new surface? Well, I actually,
I don't know. I don't know. I'm
not, I'm not too mad at the surface.
I got to use it before I really
see how it goes. You know,
at the tech specs look good. I mean
they're, they're trying something.
It was funny to watch them try to
present a product like apple though and I
don't think they have their
presentation shops down.
It froze up and froze up and
then the guy's like, yeah,
and then like twice,
like twice you can pull it up and this
guy that was selling a case for it is
like this case is the finest leather,
like a luxury costs steering wheel like
you would find on a luxury automobile.
That's the leather Alcon.
You would a sign on my
cock strap right now.
It's my Louis d string.
I cinch my balls with Butan fineness,
murdered beasts.
We cut the throat when they were young.
We personally personally clubbed
each of these baby minks is here.
That's what they're saying. If
you are soft balls of a child,
eight,
to be fair,
this software is in Beta and so
that's probably why he froze up.
But you don't want it. Don't
do a presentation unless
it's going to be solid.
Apple's really great at that.
Not that they haven't fucked up too,
but have a great experience
just with all the,
with browsing and just
10.6 this guy is just,
he's hearing the email,
it's going to be sent to him about his
job termination as he's definitely,
and of course people play games.
I can go and play any of the interesting
games that were on in the windows store
right now. It's like freezing. I can
play the game. Hide the surface. Yeah.
So no one can see it froze for all of
those and then the camera zooms in like
right, right. It. That's
the worst part of it,
you know? It looks great. My child's
college fund now as a combat.
I won't see it again. Yeah. Now why
is the camera, would you switch?
Don't excuse me just a second.
Hold on one second.
We're going to talk about this or
a company retreats. Wait a minute.
When did they just put it back and get
another one? Which Kudos on that producer.
We're having another one ready to run.
They must have had 40 back there just
in case this buggy piece of shits about
fuck up in the middle of my
presentation. Man, poor guy,
he must was sweating and he
tried to like play it off to,
you got to talk about it.
You've got to go listen,
we're going to stop that from happening.
Yeah.
Pay No attention to the
crashing on the surfaces. Silly.
So silly like crashed. Yeah.
So it's that, but I don't,
I'm not mad at the product. I
just, they got to try something.
I think it is Amazon making a smart
phones. Interesting. I think design wise,
it's just, you know like
when you sit first of all the
iPad and you're just like,
wow, that thing's sexy as fuck. You
know? And this kind of just seems to us,
I don't know it Matt. It just looked
boring. It looked kind of like, yeah,
this would have been an
awesome three years ago.
Do you know that they're coming out with
a small iPad that's the next move. Yeah.
Yeah.
They're making a note and they're making
the note bigger is what is the latest
I've Sam.
So the next model of notes actually going
to be a little bit bigger to kind of
compete with the next iPad. IPAD. Supposed
to have a phone attached to it. No,
but you either should the note, I mean
you can use it as a phone, I guess. Uh,
probably they're really trying to
bill it but wouldn't you want it
to be able to do everything if the note
could do everything but the, I kept my,
I couldn't make calls that would annoy me.
Well,
I mean your iPad now can make
calls if you Skype, Skype or voip.
It skyping people like some fucking
hack or savage who is an APP?
I think it's pretty, I didn't grandparents
are skyping at this point, I think.
I don't think that any of the elite hacks
or is out there are booting up Skype.
Do you have to afford Geeta
Skype or King's Canyon and
so you could come up with
three g? Yeah. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
How weird is that? It's great.
When you actually going to
be what phone calls are.
It's like you just need an internet
connection mean. That's to an extent.
That's what they are now. It's
just, you know, instead of Skype,
you're using their cellular tower.
It's just converting your voice to
packets and beaming it around the planet.
Again, why I like mountain men, right?
Marty gets in his plane and he flies three
hours up in for the Alaska wilderness.
There's nobody up there that poor fuck.
He has to take a bath in a a a look
like it has to heat up water and like a
garbage can. Does he have a tumbler?
Does he have a tumbler? Yeah. What's it?
Am I supposed to care if he doesn't
have a tumbler? I'm not interested.
I don't know what a tumbler is.
What's his Twitter does they have a
Twitter flicker and bill or one of those
things? Yeah, those plugs, those tumblers.
It's like where people went
when they got off of my space.
It's like I need somewhere to go and
express myself and it really annoying way.
It's actually where I think where people
are getting off to go from Facebook now
and need to park. Yeah. A lot of
people. That's humbling. Really. Yeah.
I mean it gives you that sort of
personalization and all that madness.
The Facebook thing is crazy.
I think the less indulgent people
are allowed to be the better.
So when you're allowed animated
Gif files and all that,
she don't like my glitter graphics say,
define me as a human being.
I want to embed 40 songs on a page
with some glitter and that defines me.
People for years wanted a way to define
the type of person that's instantly
defined when they have a glitter tag on
their myspace page for years. It's like,
you know,
they're not retarded,
but like did dare fucking weird.
Like it's like they tell you that like
something and you're like, come on,
read the guys who have that jam.
Stir frog is the ring tone. I'm like,
I see those commercials. And I'm like, so
what is selling that ringtone to people?
Before the ringtones, man, you couldn't
describe a guy like that before.
They were gluing tags. You would,
you would go, well she's just weird.
And then log it sounds like you're an
asshole with axe body spray though.
I mean it's the same with
your card in the war.
That whole Bot might father wears a whole
bottle of that and to this like he has
no scent glands. So when he comes to
my house, like I've had people come up,
I've had people come over to my house,
no shit.
And three days after my dad has visited,
they say your house reeks of
knock off Portuguese TrueCar.
And that's my old man. Which he
spray. No, no. It's like it's,
it's like the chill water.
He uses the knock off cool water.
Like literally I got some of that when I
was a kid. I remember putting it on him.
I love him. This is really
what I have to do to get laid.
I don't know if I'm kind
of all through with this.
Can I get you get them out and
doing their ditto if I, if I may,
that'd be great.
Thank you sir.
You have such congrats and a half on every
time I visit you. There's a new setup.
Wait till you soon.
We're going to be in low
earth orbit recording the
podcasts like this is so good.
We're branching out. So happy for
both of you. Congrats. Thank you.
We're having a good time,
man. We've been, uh,
doing a lot of comedy shows here at
the icehouse too. We're doing one, uh,
saw that Wednesday night for
folks who are interested.
It's picking up pace as we speak
right now. Committed to the show.
This is what we're going to be one of
our Wednesday night super shows don.
My errors in Greg Fitzsimmons is in an
Ari Shaffir is so just write their son.
Get the fuck out of it.
Greg was,
so I asked him to be a part of the first
lead up that we threw at at club Nokia.
Got an email. So Fis, what?
Explain to the ladies and gentlemen
again to don't know what a lead up
a lead up. Yeah. Well, I mean we
created it on a whim this year. It's a,
it's supposed to be and sort of is
a nerd carnival. So the idea is, Eh,
there's experiential zones that you
can have like an old school arcade or
cosplay or modeling with
with earth magnets and Bucky
balls and just random shit
going on on the show floor. And then
on stage we do a sort of variety show.
So there's a podcast taping,
there's VJ, Mike relm.
I'm going to come out and
jam with them on this tour.
We're taking it to 10 cities at the
end of this year, taking it around. Uh,
we're announcing the dates
next Tuesday and the location
around California. Uh, yeah, I think,
well we don't have to fly anywhere.
Not For this one. I Portland's
the closest, but we'll fly out.
We'll happily fly out and put you up and
you can do a show or take your podcasts
during it if you want.
You know,
if I could figure out a way
to book a show that night,
absolutely worth my while to go.
Absolutely.
I think a fun thing would be to do,
we've thought about doing live
podcasts before and we might do that,
but I think one thing that would be really
fun to do is do half alive podcasts,
half alive Q and a session.
So we could fuck around
and podcasts if we'd like.
But I would like it if people could
just line up and ask his question.
Right. We built that into, to lead up.
Like the idea is that so many people do
live podcasts on stage and you show up
and you just watch somebody talk and
that's it. And I'm like, but you're there,
you're physically there. There needs
to be interaction with the audience.
So we play games with them, we give out
prizes, we do Q and A's and I used to do,
Qa
is the end of all my comedy shows.
That's awesome. But it became too much.
The same questions.
Really too much.
Please,
if you go to Joe's live podcast taping,
make sure those are the only
questions you shout out.
That's all it is. Too late. They got
me. Um, which, you know, it's not bad,
but I would say like, yeah, you should
probably youtube it. You get it,
you'll get a better, you know, there's
plenty of descriptions of it on Youtube,
listening to them talk about it.
Sure. Especially, you know the,
there's great videos of you talking about
it, you know, you can, you can see that.
But it was sometimes it's fun though.
I still do it sometimes,
but I used to do it after every show.
But it's hard to close strong when
you do that. Especially cause I would,
I wouldn't want to say
no to no more questions.
So the questions would go on
for sometimes hours. I've done,
I've done like an hour of comedy than
an hour and a half more of Q and. A.
I've done that more than once. And after
awhile I was like, people like, let me go,
dude, I want to get out of
here. I'm tired of you talking,
you know. So I, I cut
it way back to I want,
I like to do like between an hour and 10
and no more than an hour and a half and
just go fucking balls out, you
know? And then as for Q and a,
I just talked to people, that's my new
thing is go outside and meet everybody.
If you've got a question I'll answer it.
But the yelling out like on
stage like that, it's like it's,
I think it would be cool if
it was a show of only Qa.
Like that's what was expected.
You know,
like people would be able to and they
would be able to get up to a microphone
and ask like when we did it at the
end with my special, yeah, there was,
there was a bunch of really funny
ones that we did from the end of a,
not my special from
Atlanta that we just did,
but my one from before from Columbus,
Ohio,
w one of the funniest parts of special
was talking to people afterwards.
Like ask the step up to the microphones
to have ridiculous questions, you know,
but it's hard to close on those.
It's hard to count that one of these is
going to be good enough to cause if he
could have an awesome show,
but if like the end of its sucks,
people remember the end of it.
Oh sure.
You got to book end it start
off big and big. That's it.
Killing for an hour and a half and have
the last five minutes eat a dick and the
show sucked. Well if you did
that, if you ate a dick on stage,
I think that's quite a closer. It depends
on whose Dick, right? Sure. Yeah. Sure.
Did you hear about the Japanese kind
of that he served his own penis.
He decided that he was asexual.
So we had this,
what am I going to do with this thing?
It's $250 a plate. Wow. And the uh,
had all these people come
over and he cooked his dick.
He cooked his dick with
mushrooms and yeah,
I would love to see the Yelp reviews
for that. He showed his dick in the bag.
He had his dick surgically
removed. Wow. First of all,
the fact that he found a doctor that's
willing to cut his fucking junk off and
then give it to him so he
could cook it like, Holy Shit,
and I don't know who the
fuck you think you are,
but the fact that you think you could
just cut your Dick and balls off and not
miss them.
I think that's silly beyond belief.
That's why when I like,
have you seen that you've seen the
BME paint Olympics video, right?
Where the guy's got his balls in a mason
jar filled with angry hornets and he's
just shaking it around.
Come on boys, get at me.
Get the Stinger in me like that
is insane to me. People are,
God damn crazy insane to me.
So glad they fixed the AC.
Does it work?
Do you think it works?
It doesn't seem like it works.
This is right here.
It feels cool.
And we're going into some of the
beak from Yoga. Yeah, we need to,
we have to think about that.
We found a doctor when we first
launched attack of the show.
It's one of my favorite segments that
only six people saw cause nobody watched
our show when we first launched it.
But that launch week we did some crazy
shit and one of them was someone yelled
across the office, they're like, your ass
got served. Like oh okay. And we went,
wait, could you serve a webpage
out of someone's ass hole?
And we did the research
and sure enough you can,
we've got a little USB web server
thumb drive. We registered your ass,
got served.com slipped it into a condom
and on live television put it in a
coworker's asshole and
fired up web server in
his colon and you could go live to his
asshole and leave a message on his wall,
which was like, you know, scrolling
on his colon and he existed. I was,
it was crazy. It was amazing. We got
away with that on live TV. Did you show?
We had him behind a screen silhouetted
like ace Ventura Style and the doctor
went back there and be
modulated his voice.
But I was standing right next to it
with me. The little microphone. Oh,
it was brilliant. Your ascots or that's
hilarious. Yeah, it was awesome. Too Bad.
Six people saw it. Oh, I saw
it. Well thank you. Yeah,
because I can find five more.
We can have a reunion special.
That was the beauty of wheat.
That was the beauty of DVR because
that was one of the few shows,
a tackle the show that I enjoyed.
Kind of like watching the
news almost every day.
I know it was kept up the day
and then stuff like that. So I,
I mean I might've had like 20 episodes
at a time and only watch like seven or
eight of them. I'll take
that. But I always, you know,
it was a fun show man,
and I really liked how it progressed and
I was actually really sad to hear that
you left. But I understand how, what
do you, what are you up to now? Uh,
lots, lots. Um, you know, doing
a lot of podcasts, you know,
when the air conditioning.
Yeah.
I mean that's what I'm getting
into mostly is HPAC stuff. No,
I can fix your air conditioning for you.
I've been reading up a lot now. I, uh,
I left in a, I started a company called
super creative. Super Creative. Dot.
TV is our site. Thank you. Thank you. It
was originally a, uh, literally was like,
what's the least creative
name I could come up with?
It explains what we do cause I'm like,
I'm not spending weeks coming up with a
name for double Helix Infusion Studios
Llc. Fuck that. We're super
creative. That's what we'll
do. You know. So, uh, uh,
so created it and we uh, we sold a
show to Scifi, which we're doing now.
I think I, you know what,
it's far enough along.
We haven't actually put pen to paper,
but I'm doing a new mission and my
series that will probably announce it.
Comicon, we're doing lead up. Um, we're
doing a whole bunch of randomness.
That's a pretty flashy intro.
That's what the winning,
the most amazing intro is ever.
Oh, thank you. Oh, oh shit.
So what we do, what we do really well is
hype up websites so we can crash them.
Is that server still in his ass? That's
where it's being served from right now.
That's hilarious. Yeah. Someone
I hired Microsoft to do my uh,
my demo site. There's a runtime
error and tried to do that today.
I tried to do what today,
tried to do that same stuff today.
Probably never be able to put them.
It was really, it was kind of, it was,
it was censorship wasn't a huge
issue with the tag of the show.
We were really able to
get away with a lot,
but they're definitely
came to a point where we,
there's no way those ideas could even
be the thing that you tried to do them,
you know, they get shot
down, you know, it was weird.
There was a lot that I tried to do, which
be surprised me that it got shot down.
Like chase a greased pig in the studio.
It took me like four years to
be able to do that. I wanted to,
in the middle of an interview,
have a guy come out and ringing
a cow bell and yell like sweet.
And then the graphics role and in a
fucking greased pig is released in the
studio and we all try to grab it because
dumbest fucking thing in the world.
And yeah, this, well, I had my moment
on our thousandth episode show.
I got to catch a grease pig and studio.
It was fucking brilliant television.
Except the moment when I leap
in front of the pig and the pig pork pig
looks scared. It was a small little pig.
I'm like, oh, now I just feel
bad. This pig is in studio lights.
There's people cheering. We
got hay everywhere. So it
was, we made the best of it,
but it was, uh, it was doing shit like
that was fun. I'm gonna miss that.
I stopped eating pigs for
awhile. Really? I eat them now,
but for a long time I stopped eating them
because I watched a documentary called
something. My brother's
keeper, I think it was,
it was about these two guys
that were accused of a crime.
I forget what the crime is,
but they were,
they were a bit slow and they were living
in a rural area and they ran a farm
and they,
when they went to a kill a pig,
you could tell the pig
knew what the fuck was up.
You could tell the pig was running away.
Pig was terrified and he put that
gun up and pig's head and boom,
and he did it in front of the other pigs.
Pigs remember that shit.
They know what the fuck is going on
when you come up to him with that gun.
And when I saw that and I saw them like,
wow, that thinks smart. I think smart.
And it knows all,
they're incredibly sooner.
People know other dirty,
filthy, disgusting animals.
Actually incredibly intelligent.
That's kind of fucked
I,
that's the only thing that I think of
when I think of as us being like related
to animals. We love animals. It's only
to me it's only intelligent animals.
But when I find out in the pig as
smart as a dog or smarter, I go, Ooh,
that's a smart thing. And that some
people kill pigs as pets or keep picks,
keeps pigs rather as pets. I'm like,
Ooh, they're probably smart. Right.
But something stupid like a fish
can suck my dick. I don't know.
I've never really,
you know what I mean?
It's like I don't keep around.
Actually, I don't feel,
I don't feel connected to
that fish at all. Right.
And I only feel connected to things.
I can think if I can win it in a midway
game and flush it down three weeks later
how and shoot it in the head and the
other cows just go, what happened?
Well that was loud. Fucking loud as shit.
I'm going to walk you over here now.
Can you believe that they,
that they got flogged raw,
like the most insane thing
helps me shots some stupid.
Meanwhile you can eat goose so dumb.
I'm just can't eat delivery. I mean,
how about like, look, I understand
the argument of there were certainly,
there was a percentage of farms that were
torturing animals essentially to make
it much like the way they torture
veal to make it. But yeah,
it wasn't even that man. Have you ever
seen it? The way they, first of all,
the way most of them do it, the the,
the fucking ducks actually hover around
feeding tube because they want it.
Right.
And people talk about being shackled
in and their heads are thrilled,
wouldn't holding, they're using plunger
sticks to jam it down their throat.
That's the propaganda.
And Look,
I'm sure that a percentage
of farms we're doing that,
I'm sure people treat him like shit,
you make that illegal.
You don't make the
fucking biproduct illegal.
Why is it not okay to take that one piece,
but it's okay to take the whole,
well it's
no, no, it's not legal to,
there's organic Fagua to where
they don't force feed them.
They just use the liver.
Sure. Illegal to now.
So let me just, all those stupid fucking
duck. It's still, you can still eat duck.
He could still lead goose. You can
glaze them and them from a window. They
essentially made an Oregon the
preparation of an Oregon illegal.
It's so stupid because first of all,
organs are some of the most nutritious
things you can eat. You know,
liver is really good for you.
It's like that's the reason why wolves
go for the liver as the reason why cats
eat your organs. They were like
super healthy for your heart.
Hearts are so healthy.
It's really like really like maximum
proteins just like that guy serving up his
dick in Japan. Do you think
in the near future, so health,
I'm not talking about the
nutritional aspects of it,
I'm telling you about the concept of eat.
Like there being a restaurant near future
where human organs are served because
they're grown in a fridge somewhere
out of petri dishes or whatever.
Like we're going to slice into year off
the back of this mouse and you're gonna
eat it, but a liver or something else.
Well, you know, eating parts of human can.
Jacob Crutchfield disease.
He can cause I'm a mad cow disease.
The same essential disease at
mad when mad cow is somehow you,
when you feed cows, brain matter of
other cows and that's what they do.
They grind up every fucking part of
the cow and then feed it to other cows.
It's really insane. Disgusting. It's not
just disgusting. It's like psychopathic.
It's like they've done something beyond
horrendous that not only do they eat
these animals and murder these
animals on a regular basis,
but then they feed them to each
other and they feed them protein.
Which by the way is not what they
eat. Man. That's not their food.
Their food is grass. Okay. And they're
not even supposed to be eating corn.
And the reason why they get so fucking
fat is because we feed them corn.
Cows eat grass. That's what
they eat. That's it, period.
So we're feeding him other cows.
Well they get this crazy mad cow disease,
which is essentially nature's way of
keeping you for being a fucking Cannibal,
was the same disease that cannibals in
New Guinea, get cannibals in New Guinea,
get these fucking horrible neurological
disorder where they have the shakes and
it's full fucking people, man. So I think,
I don't think we'll ever see a human organ
restaurant because I think if you eat
them, you'll probably get sick. I mean it
only makes sense. I know the prions are,
I believe it's brain matter
that that holds them.
That's where they get it from initially.
This talk is exactly what I needed because
I needed somebody to tell me that I
couldn't do it. That will be the
catalyst. This is my motivator to make,
it's a pretty incredible things
in petri dishes. Right? I mean,
aren't they recreating bladders now?
They done that with,
I think they've done that with um,
they've created a bladder and a
and installed it into a person.
Yeah. There's no runtime errors.
I think a bladder, you know,
it's like sort of a bag,
so it's probably like a good safe thing
to start out with before something that
pumps things, you know, before they
actually make a heart right now.
I'm sure they've done it.
I'm sure they've done it and put
it in a chimp somewhere and popped.
Open the chest and let's
see if this powers it.
Let's see what happens when we do this.
Sure. They have. Yeah, man. Chimps,
chimps that gets tested on,
I bet they were really angry.
Can you imagine what a fucking shit
life it is to be as smart as a champ,
which is probably like what smarter a
chimp or a person with down syndrome.
Is it clothes?
I would have no idea.
I think down syndrome is such a wide
spectrum. Right? Like Syndrome Lord knows.
Yeah,
right.
Because corky had a very mild
version ever from the facts of life.
Remember Axa was it fax facts
now that was a wonder years or
what was that show?
The only corky,
no growing pains is the one
with Kirk Cameron wasn't it?
I'm still upset that I asked that
question because I know that's,
that's all I'm going to get in all caps
in my Twitter feed for the next three
weeks. And then was life goes
on Bro. You to know Corky,
you remember growing pains in my arm
before Kirk Cameron became one of the most
awesome.
He's brilliant.
Why is it banana shaped the way it is? I
never told you to explain that shit. Joe.
I actually was on a plane with Kirk
Cameron recently and he was just sitting
there looking so sad and depressed and I,
cause it was one of those things where uh,
I was waiting for somebody else to put
like their luggage up so I was just
standing right next to him and he's just
sitting there like looking at his phone,
like looking past this phone,
not even looking what's on the screen.
And he just sat there and then like some
woman came up to him and he just looked
up and went like did those are like
little smile but it was so weird
being too wouldn't you can imagine every
day the guy is fighting off the gay
with every fiber of his being.
He is just clenching his teeth and finding
out if you really want to save Kirk
Cameron,
this is what you do.
If you're a big gay guy sitting on his
lap and pull your cock out and it'll suck
along it like a baby to its
mother's breasts, banana peel on it.
First security.
That's what he's doing.
He's just fighting off the gay
tooth and nail and claw. And Fang.
So funny to me how other people who are
most outspoken against homosexuality are
just look at him.
He's so obviously gang.
You can't get any obviously
gayer than Kirk Cameron.
Not there's anything wrong with
being obviously die either.
I mean for the guy to be happy,
she'd just come out of the closet.
All of them just come out.
What do you think about the Tom Cruise,
Scientology, Surrey or whatever.
You know,
it's amazing.
The Tom Cruise already has a new Ukrainian
beauty picture of him and her holding
hands are ready in a magazine like
a such an obviously stage picture.
You're like, Scientology
are bad motherfuckers cause
they're still rocking it.
Old School in 2012 all right.
They're putting together storylines.
They're creating like narratives.
They have like a whole fucking publicity.
So like,
like whole area,
a department that like figures out how
to handle that when you Tama girlfriend
and we need Tahmo girlfriend.
No.
Right. It's like a newsroom.
Like that's it. They're,
they're the the like the News Corp
in New York step pitches
in New York. Shit. Okay.
We need Tom with a hot Russian
right now and Tom. Okay,
you're going to go on Ellen this time
and jump on the couch and you're going to
say you're in love and you're,
I don't care if you're 50 and
you want to fix your career,
jump on that woman's couch. All
things Seaton the, the videos of them,
like people trying to go
into their welcome to the
public kind of festivals and them coming
out and aggressively swarming around
people and screaming, what's your issue?
What's your problem? What are you hiding?
What are you afraid of? It's
that's, that's scary shit.
They love the cornea bigot too.
That's a big one called people bigots.
Scientology's fascinating organization
to me and just like the cops help people
though, man. No doubt about it.
I have a neighbor who was a scientologist
who's on Nice fucking guy, man.
He's a great guy and he had helped him.
Man,
he tells you all the great things that
he did for him and how he helped his
business,
helped his life and helped us focus and
this and that and vogue and believes in
it. Who are you to tell them differently?
Kevin Pereira. I'm nobody. I'm nobody.
Joe Rogan. Do you think, um,
how much of a Tom Cruise's life is
surrounded by Scientologists cause he just
like, you know, Scientology Bible got it.
The leaders I think is he the head guy?
He wears the pig helmet at the meeting.
You know, like he's the one that's
like the deepest in and I think,
I think there's like a group of like
probably like six main players and he's
like the one of the head guys,
you know,
you've just created your own fucking
council of it. Right? Seriously.
When they meet in their hollowed
out volcano, ever seen the video?
The staff were full. He's like one
of the most powerful guys ever.
Can you pull up the video of him in the,
do you know the Scientology
video where he is a,
it's a video that wasn't supposed to,
it was like supposed to play it like
a conference or something. Right.
And he was supposed to be in the,
yeah,
I dunno what you had said. Tom
Cruise, creepy speech, Scientology.
But whatever it is, they, they
had it set up and say, excuse me.
They had it set up in
this, um, like a hole.
It was like a whole auditorium of people
that were like watching this tape.
Right. Wasn't that like cheering
along with it and shed him?
Am I remembering that right?
No, I think it was. And he was like
an annual meeting, like a seminar.
Like you sit through that and then they
offer you a timeshare and then you get
to go skiing.
Poor Katie Holmes,
poor Jason. But didn't she sign out? Like
I've always heard, I've always heard, hey,
sign up. They sign up for it.
Yeah. And it's like, sure, but,
and you get this much money
monitor career to come back. I just
wanted to be relevant, you know,
and guess what man, that's the only
way to do it for a lot of these girls,
you know, these middling girls, you know,
they're doing pretty good there. Okay.
And you know,
five years goes by and she's
39 ou pass and that's it.
It's over.
So you've got to make a,
you got to bust a move before your fucking
rice runs out of the fuck it sand out
of the thing.
What it was
sand out of the hourglass or the that
thing. The old rice rice do that. Why
did I feel like there's a similar
measuring devices, rice and some cultures.
I'm sure there are. Yeah. Maybe it
was gotta be someone figured that out.
I spend way too much time thinking
about ancient civilizations of ancient
cultures. Got gotta be honest with
you. Yeah, it's a real problem.
It's a distraction.
From thinking about current events,
when do you think we're going to wipe
ourselves out or upload ourselves into the
machines so it doesn't matter.
Like how soon it seems again like
it's going to happen in our lifetime.
It seems like the leaps
are coming so fast.
Did you see the new TSA screening devices?
Whitten for which?
Look at them all. Slapping.
He's got a metal. He did it.
It's got a metal to metal.
The religion,
I have never met
a more competent the world
or background agent Cody.
I'm hollering and more compassionate being
outside of what I've experienced from
LRH and I've met the leaders of leaders.
Okay. I've met them all.
So I say to you, sir, cob,
we are lucky to have you and thank you.
Beautiful. We will have,
it wasn't, he's beautiful.
What's an l Ron busted on like a boat
in international waters having sex with
underage people. Yup. Okay. Something,
well maybe not, but I said Yup.
What made it so there we go. Update
the Wiki. Can we just get that?
And that's not even the one man. There's
one where he was appearing by tape,
right? Yeah. Yeah. That's
the one I originally found.
But I thought you were talking about
that one. That was beautiful too though.
He's beautiful. He's just so charismatic.
Would sign up for five years with that.
So that should, that helped my
career. If I just had an inkling of,
of the possibility that maybe
he would hang out with me,
I could just write cultures. That's
it. I think at the music, like
once you know these tools and you know
that they work, it's just not good enough.
And I'm just doing okay.
Traveling the world and meeting
the people that I've met, you know,
talking with these leaders,
get various fields
they want help and they're depending on
people who know and who can be effective
in doing
that is our responsibility to do that.
It is the time. Now is
the time. Stop it. Stop.
This is beautiful. How he shot
me. Fucking beautiful. You better.
You better know it. And
if you don't, you know,
go and learn it.
What?
Oh, that's the option. If I don't know
what I need to learn it, she's, it's not
the end of it.
The end of it is what I wanted to hear.
What he says that if
you stop by an accident,
you know you have to do something
cause you're a scientist.
It's an eight minute video of Sec.
Oh here I'll try to skip. Don't,
don't make me get my dick hard.
Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That's too intense for me. I
just loved the music and possible music.
I love the, you know, I love all
of them are religious mission.
Should you choose to accept
it and an Iq distresses. Yeah.
The conviction.
I love the,
the fake act or intensity involved in it
and I know that he's just thinking of,
I have one more hour this and I'm
going to fuck everyone who's got this.
Like 10 dudes just waiting for him,
prepping them right now.
Like a horse that knows he's on the end
of the trail and he's getting back to
the feedback there. She knows there's
12 dudes in the back of warming up.
It might be ready
that I've done everything
I could every day.
Think about those people out
there who are depending on us.
I think it does make me, she'll
have more work. I need more help
and I'll get those spectators.
You're into playing field
or out of the arena,
the playing field or out of the
arena. That has great, yeah.
You're there with us who
have the answers and we have,
we can provide all the help
or ladies and gentlemen,
please watch the whole thing
because there's so much glory in it.
There's so much awesome that's in it.
It's so ridiculous, but you know what man?
It's like we,
we value charisma like that so much
that a guy like that who can step up and
tell you what Scientology can do to
maximize you and that you will be a better
person. It's not. If you don't become
a but you will be a better person.
Thank you very much.
The reason you're not right now is
because you haven't joined. Come on dude.
How crazy do you have to be to be wearing
a metal to wear a fucking Olympic gold
medal bigger than the Olympic medal? The
date they said, what's the Olympic medal?
Mega 10% bigger because this is important.
Melt those Olympic rings into one
giant metal and make it match his eyes.
We make it out of the gold we took from
the fillings at Auschwitz and yeah,
that's special evil goal that we have
saved up that we'd been a radiating and
saying mean things to her years.
One fucking pile of all the gold that
they know was made in and gotten through
the worst circumstances like black
beards, fucking pirate treasure. I mean,
we know he murdered babies for
this goal or this is the goal.
I want mold into that. What do you think?
What do you, what are you watching?
The flights.
You're Tom Cruise screensaver cut.
Then all your photos of that half naked.
Okay, stop right there. Back up a second.
Think about this real quick.
Look at him with Val Kilmer.
Now think about what he looks like,
which is the fucking same.
He's showing him the house, but inside I'm
in this photo. What Val Kilmer? Look it.
He's saying,
I'm getting you to the elbow.
I snack Kilmer Val Kilmer has continued
to age whereas Tom Cruise had,
he got to a certain point and then just
stopped dying because he's been eating
from a human liver restaurant and you
don't know about it yet. The Petri dish,
human liver restaurant,
he goes into the cryo freezer,
especially pigs is Oregon's as in love
with Katie's back in the day. Meanwhile,
what is he thinking about their cock?
That's what he's thinking about cock.
He's thinking about cost there. He's
thinking of a cocky. He's, he's,
he's ready for an actual yelling for cock.
I actually want to say on the record that
I don't think he's gay and he doesn't
want like that because at
my name is Brian Ryko in my,
usually my stage name is Red
Van and I disagree with everyone
here. Mr. Cruz and I'm sorry. Oh,
what'd you do it if he doesn't,
even if he doesn't want cock, I
think you should try it. Yeah,
because it might be his thing.
Brian,
would you do a five year
stint with Tom Cruise?
If it meant unlimited wealth
and career success? Five months.
Let's just say five months in my compound
I have to have sex or just hang out
with him for Frankie have to, you have to
either fuck or be fucked by Tom Cruise.
One of the two has to happen for sure.
Unlimited wealth. Unlimited wealth. Sure.
And success. Would you do now
career success five months
at Tom Cruise sex slave?
Absolutely not. You wouldn't
for unlimited? Well No.
What does unlimited wealth?
I don't know. It just never
having to worry about it. Yeah,
but could you buy like jets
and shit? Certainly. You can
imagine if your butthole,
you're letting the guy fuck your
butthole was worth that much.
It was like there was a way you
can negotiate it. I'm sure it is.
This subtle salt out there somewhere now.
People think of it that they're like
sucked your Dick just for dinner and like,
really? I could've gotten unlimited
wealth if I just got a better agent.
If we were talking about Zac Efron,
they maybe a man.
Don't let me get lunch with those eyes.
Don't look at those. Don't, don't. Um,
how many guys do you think are in
Hollywood that are in the closet that are
forced to be in the closet because
they play action star, I think.
I think there's a,
I think there's a shit ton of m and I
also think there's a lot of guys who who,
well, I mean it's like the guys who go
gay for pay, like who aren't gay guys,
but they're like, fuck, if I got to
take a dick to make fucking ends meet,
let's go crazy. Some dude's just
have lower standards. They'll,
they'll let things happen. Looks
maybe, maybe I call it adventurous Joe.
Fuck you for putting a label on
anybody who might do that out there.
Anybody at all.
If you want to do it though.
It seems like a company like Scientology
is fucking awesome to have in your
corner. It seems like they,
I mean, I don't know. We're
just totally speculating.
You sure. What role, if any of
that and speculating by the way,
whether or not he's actually get
much surgery. Certainly. No, no.
It starts to be crazy.
I just,
the notion of a Scientology to like if
I were to join it as a, as a d list,
struggling actors,
web celebrity type,
if I would have joined Scientology and
kick in a hundred grand the first year,
maybe 200 grand,
that's going to buy me to a certain level
where I'm in meetings with people who
are heads of movie studios and
making decisions and they go,
look at this young gentleman
here who's paying in and he's,
he's playing the game.
Let's put him in that movie,
getting a little bit more because we know
he's going to contribute to the church.
You know what, he's going to be
an ambassador. But how much that,
how much did they actually control?
That's the big question is like they
obviously control Tom Cruise because he's
really successful. I mean,
you look at Tom Cruise,
Tom Cruise has been in a
bunch of really big hit movie.
So that's why they control him.
That's why they handle his business
because he's a massive investment.
Sure he's worth a ton of money.
But how, you know he's that guy,
but for they're already there.
You know what I'm saying? Well,
how much can they do for you?
How much can they get?
How much could they get Kevin Pereira
help? How much could they weasel you in?
How much should it have a good
pitch? Which is, you know,
maybe they'd get me a Hulu web series.
I know in mission impossible five
just so you know, I'll take, you know,
that's what I mean. Like they could help
me out on a certain level. And then as,
as you grow with them and they help you,
then you contribute more and they help
groom you for that. They are essentially
like a form of a talent agency for some,
I'm sure for some they're probably
a beard agency for others.
There are talent agency.
Do you know what I mean?
Like they just offer all different
servers. What do you need?
You're in the church now and they
have your secrets. They audit you,
they know all about your past and your
history and that's part of the initiation
process is that you divulge everything
to them. So then you hear the whole wheat
good. They are Cuban secrets. Amazing.
It's pretty fucking sweet. Yeah. I mean,
think about how many dudes that must
have the fucking inside scoop on John
Travolta and the like, we ain't hear it.
Scientology or coming to do a mission.
Wow. That was amazing.
Like was there a group on,
on just gay Mizuho's disorders like,
and it just came out of the woodwork.
Yeah. Once one guy came out
it, the guys were like, oh no,
he did and I'm going to get mine too.
Yeah, absolutely. If you're stepping
forward, I am. I wonder if they got paid.
They got paid. My money must
have been exchanged. Well,
they suddenly started withdrawing
all their lawsuits and you know that,
I don't know if that's, maybe they
were frivolous. I don't know. But uh,
he's just come out. Just come
on now, dude. No one cares.
Yeah. Well look it, I mean,
I'm sure like Anderson Cooper recently
came out and I did that matter. I mean,
did that,
no,
the people that care suck, you know,
it's not funny that people are gay.
What's funny is that people are
straight pretending they're gay. Right?
Or rather gay bars. Pretentious.
Straight. That's what's funny. Right?
It's not the actual being gay.
I know a lot of gay people,
but it's hilarious when there's fucking
obviously gay people like the Kirk
Cameron.
I'm just shocked whenever there's a
legislative setback and like, you know,
being gay in the gay rights movement,
like you can still easily draw a line
that's parallel to any other time there's
been a debate involving marriage or any
other discrimination suit and you go, Yo,
that was wrong. We were
wrong about discriminating.
That's right. We were wrong.
We figured that out and yet here we
are discriminating and mass and volume
loudly and openly and it's,
you know,
it's a platform for some people
politically and that's, that's okay.
Right now we're okay with that.
Even with all the knowledge and
access to history that we have,
we're okay with that.
Well, religion is always
been the big, I mean,
if you want to look at one thing
that's oppresses gay people,
nothing has suppressed,
gave you more than religion and almost
every person who is against people who
are gay being married is
religious. I mean, that is just a,
it's not an ideological viewpoint. It's,
it's, it's a religious viewpoint. Sure.
It's where it comes from there. The
ideology that, that really, that,
that action is,
is negative in any way is connected direct
directly to religion and for no one,
I know that's an eighth
for a myriad of societal issues though,
from religion to abortion to whatever.
I mean, the main thing people say,
well, it's a political issue now.
It's actually a religious issue
and one political side. At times.
It ebbs and flows. We'll side
more with religions. Well,
it's traditionally Republican,
but
Ronald Reagan,
Ronald Reagan started all that shit off.
That's where the big slide in
this country came before then,
religion really was separated from
politics. It wasn't a big thing,
but the Ronald Reagan, they went
after the fucking religious right.
They knew they were a powerful force.
They knew they could rally up and they
could protest and they could, you know,
they could,
they could do
payment,
hand out the pamphlets,
tell every Sunday beam the message into
people's heads if that's the whales,
fucking mindless drones that need a,
a purpose to live,
are happy to be a part of
that organization and they
were in locked in those
sons of bitches.
I always think though, I got to figure
out, for me what my spiritual parallel is,
because every story that I read about,
you know,
everything from placebo effect to
spiritual people heal quicker because they
believe that they will heal quicker.
I've got to figure out the proper way and
the healthy way to unlock that with me
because I'm such a skeptic
about everything and that
help you that with any pill,
with any drug, with any, anything,
even just positive thought,
I'll eventually convinced myself that it
will not work. I can help you. Oh please,
sure
I've already conquered this.
Didn't help you tremendously.
He life is a simulation and it's
a simulation for your own benefit.
You live in a future,
a sexless future where people take
orgasm pills and most breeding is done
through some sort of a
genetic manipulation where
he just fucking recreate
people in laboratories and there's no sex,
there's no meat.
You don't eat steak, you don't talk,
you use your brain and it's beautiful.
And we've organized and you know,
basically evolved past the
point of physical violence
and pleasure and all sorts
of different things that are
essentially just tricks of genetics.
But it's boring. No one's getting their
dick sucked the music fucking terrible.
You can't go out and get a good steak.
So we have decided to,
in case our consciousness in a simulation
and the simulation is we are in the
roaring twenties of the technology age.
We live back in a time
where things were crazy.
We could go to a store and buy a fucking
600 horsepower car and just drive.
The speed limit is 55 miles
an hour rank rank. Meanwhile,
you can go buy a Shelby Mustang,
600 fucking horse.
So were the matrix,
but we got to pay for patches,
Peng,
and it's,
that's part of the fun of it all is that
everything is corrupt and ridiculous.
Part of the fun of a Batman movies
effect. There's bad guys. Okay.
Part of the fun of a of our
life is the fact that yeah,
we do live in this ridiculously
corrupt society. Yeah. When you,
when you raise your voice and you,
you stand up and you tell people,
this is fucking bullshit. That does
feel good. It's part of the game.
It's all part of the fun and reality. It
doesn't, it doesn't matter at all. You're,
you're a simulation and you
probably will never die. You will,
you will live in this simulation and it
will fucking blackout one day and you'll
wake up in the middle
of a fucking, uh, uh,
some sort of a forest fire with your
friends and your, you're working in the,
in the, in the blazing heat trying to put
out this fire and that's your real life
because you,
you know,
you woke up in some new reality and then
it's going to keep going on, on a table,
licking salt. It'll go on forever.
There's no ending. You don't get a break.
You know,
you don't get to sit behind the pearly
gates someday and reminisce and try to
figure out if it all went
the way you wanted it to.
And well next time I'm going
to come back as a baby. No,
it's just one thing that never ends.
The leaving.
That doesn't make me feel like my plantar
fasciitis is going to heal quicker.
Well you got to put yourself
in a different state of mind.
You got to decide with your mind cause
that's how you control this video game.
You got to decide with your mind to be
the hero in your own story and that if
you were going to be the hero in your
own story and the story was going to be
fucking bad ass,
what were the hero do right now?
How would the hero get his shit
together? It's a long, I need to do it.
I need to invent dragons and dragons and
hover boards set. Maybe you could do it.
That's the calling. If that's your
calling, that's everybody has one,
but whatever your calling is,
you just got to decide you're the hero
in the story. What would the hero do?
It's really not that hard.
This fucking air conditioning sucks.
Yeah, it's pretty broad. You don't mind
if I could let him in here just so he
can look at it and check things. Oh,
we're doing podcasts.
Jesus Christ right now. No,
I mean like if you can just walk in
the background, you know this is,
we want to come back
right now. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, sure. Okay, cool. Got It. I think
we're going to just wrap this up anyway.
Right? Are we done? What
time is it? Two hours.
15 do you wanna keep talking?
Happy to if you'd like.
Let's let that dude come in here and
all right. It's pretty, it's
really hot. It's swampy.
I hear tropical birds crying and
my taint right now, it is rough.
You could rent a boat through it.
The poor air conditioning is
trying to do something ridiculous.
This place is filled with holes.
If you look at all these doors right here,
you could see straight through. There's
no insulation in this place. Sure.
There's a fucking windows right there.
The Sun comes blazing down those
windows and it's 106 degrees outside and
there's rabid bats in Pasadena. Have
you heard about that shit, dude?
They found a rabid bat in Pasadena.
Now they're warning the residents in
this particular area where we're at,
they says viral marketing, Vat about
marketing for a new Batman movie.
It's all it is.
This is leading up to comicon.
Could you imagine those sons of bitches?
Can you imagine if they
started manipulating the news?
They said, I mean, look, shitty movies.
Certainly. If you think so. Yeah. Well,
I mean maybe not releasing a rabid bat,
but I mean releasing the news report
about it. It would certainly do that.
We're going to bioengineer some,
some rats and give them a a poison and
then send them out for the new movie.
Willard, we're pretty sure we know
how to stop him. We're going to just,
they did that.
They would really attracted to blood with
the blood in the streets all come out.
We'll kill them all.
Don't worry.
That would do that at comicon.
They need to just release a patient zero
at comicon to promote the new resident
evil and just let them walk around
and know that one guy at comicon,
if you meet them, you get
a free tee shirt, but I'll
also give you a Zombie aids.
Have you seen the giant rats
they found in New York City?
Some of them they found in the Bronx.
Well,
apparently it's a type of rat that's like,
uh,
let me, let me Google this. It's,
Brian isn't here, but it's a,
it's a huge fucking rat.
Like so big. Like you,
you look at it and you'll wait
Iranian size or like clydesdale size.
I'm talking like, like, like
a Johnson. Really? Yeah.
Like one of those dots in New York.
Yeah.
There it is. It's on a
fucking, it's crazy, man.
It's on a spear and there,
there's more than one of them.
One of them they killed.
They're sending exterminators into the
sewers with spheres to kill these rats.
The size of that got killed it
with a pitchfork. Oh Shit. Yeah.
Yeah. They're, they're, they're
not a rabbit or ferret or songs.
It's apparently a type of rat.
It's not like a regular street rat that
people have had as pets and released and
apparently they get fucking big man.
And that's right to see where
people have always, you know,
heard about rats in New York
City. Like, yeah. It's rats.
The size of catch in New York
City. Well, there really are. Yeah.
Those are cruising around surface streets.
That's not like miles under the ground
and a sewage tunnel or something.
Those guys are running around. Oh yeah,
they were there in houses and Shit.
You know, they're digging their way
into people's houses. Jesus. Yeah.
There's other,
there's another rat that they've found
a in a shoe shop and it was insanely big
here. It's going to get to the point
where cockroaches are this one right here,
the size, like the size of this
rap, they found this rat in a, um,
in a shoe shop in New York City.
Uh,
it looks like a shovel. The size
of that fucking thing. Yeah,
it's a cat. Insane. And meanwhile there's
this many of them as there are people
in New York City's as many, I hope they
don't ever figure out how to organize
God. Why if one rat was coming out,
you'd shit your pants. You know,
I just freak out when I see
a spider the size of a dime.
But the coming down from the reality
is they're eating something, right?
So there's gotta be, it's
like set up, it's set up.
This is their part of the ecosystem.
It's just a part that nobody in those
fancy towers once ever think about who,
what, what is, what is
pray for that route?
Are they eating other giant rats
that side's dumpster diving,
like certainly eat each other. I've, I've
had rats in my garage, in each other.
I killed a big rat,
wants left the body out in the
garage that got killed in a trap.
It was like midnight.
I didn't feel like I was lazy.
I didn't feel like cleaning the travel.
So I'll fucking clean it tomorrow.
I went out there tomorrow and the rat
was gone. Everything but the tail,
they had eaten them. Jesus had his
bones, dude, they had everything. I mean,
it was crazy. There's, it
just left a little bit of
skin and some like, you know,
parts of their feet. I mean, it was
insane. Just enough to identify the body.
And these were big fucking
rats to the rats in the,
I was in Encino and the time and
the hills, you know, above, um,
above the valley who's
a lot of rats up there.
God damn was a lot of rats and coyotes
everywhere. I mean you want to,
they're just those ones,
the fuckers,
they just keep checking in with mother
nature to see if we wiped ourselves out
yet. They're like looking around.
Nope. Nope. Lights are still on. Yeah,
there's still people here. Yeah,
we're waiting. We're waiting.
We're waiting till we take it over again.
And it's not daisy yet.
You guys have a nuke each
other. Okay. All right.
Well we'll cruise back and then come
back out. We'll run towards the blast.
When there's a nuclear blast,
they're going to run towards it.
Just start fucking just eating
the first thing they find first, the
first dead person they find. Have you, uh,
have you heard about this? Uh,
it's the, the game called daisy.
It's an add on to this. This is very
realistic. Military Simulator Arma two.
But they,
they,
this guy made like one guy is making a
little indie game called daisy and you
start off on it.
It's online and you're completely
defenseless and helpless and on your own.
And there's a small Zombie outbreak and
there's a lot of human beings running
around and you very quickly have to figure
out what is more threatening to you.
You have to get your gun, get your food,
get your ammo, like try to meet up.
You can meet up with random
people and talk to them,
but nine times out of 10 that random
person's going to shoot you in the face.
And that's what's so insane is that like
they built the simulator where it's a
Zombie outbreak, but just like
the real Zombie outbreak would be,
the real threat are your
fellow human beings.
It has nothing to do with the
zombies, you know? Yeah. In fact,
one guy a blogged,
he was in a town like clearing it and
these dudes came out of the bush with
automatic rifles and like camouflage in
the average lifespan for this game is
only like a handful of hours.
Most people get in,
they scrounge around people kill people
kill you. Cause they can. Yeah, exactly.
They'll take your supplies.
Once you see that you're good enough.
So you have to really take care of your
character and be stealthy and then try
to build it up.
So this guy is in the middle of the
city and like six dudes pop out,
put them at gunpoint and they said,
we're going to kill you unless you become
our slave. And the guy was like, fuck,
I don't want to lose my
character. And they said, listen,
you just follow us around for a few hours
to send you into cities to scout for
us.
We'll defend you if you get attacked,
but you have to be our slave and do what
we say or else we're going to kill you
right now. And the guy was
like, all right, let's do this.
They made them kneel and pose for photos.
He was like a catch like people do this.
And he said that at the end of it like
that he went into cities and scouted for
him and he really felt like he was one
with the group after a few hours and then
like he went and they went to like clear
a bus and they got ambushed and slowly
one by one they were all getting killed
and he felt so bad. He was like, Oh man,
my group got killed and he quickly
identified with a group of online captors
were Stockholm Syndrome.
Yeah.
But in the matter of minutes in
the virtual world of like, well uh,
all right I guess I'll go along with you.
Here we go.
Well you could say that that guy's
an idiot. Well I mean what else,
what were his choices?
Play another game sucks so much
Twitter form just allowed
someone to be a cunt anonymously.
You can't have that, you
know that's that's that's
those are work. Does it work?
Can you came?
That's how all online games are.
That's why 12 year olds call you with
current and you know tea bag you every
five seconds every on ongoing
that just veneer of anonymity.
Lets people eviscerate each other. It
brings out the worst Torsten human beings.
Well, when ever you have no
consequences for your actions.
It's a weird thing that we figured out
how to do is that everyone's getting
connected.
But in doing so,
there's going to be some sort of a weird
period where it's still sort of working
itself out where there's anonymity
and interaction at the same time.
And that's sort of where
we're at right now. Yeah.
We have both anonymity and interact.
Hyper interaction.
Hyperconnectivity really can't even
take place anywhere else. I mean,
how else could that even take place
except the Internet in the nature and the
natural world that devry no fail
safes. Well, I got a hole in an adult
theater.
Even then you can fuck somebody else and
not know who was on the other side of
the divide.
You could
good. Then I feel your teeth stop, stop,
stop. And even then there's consequences.
Sure. How you feel bad
about your Dick Sucking job?
Well, you know what's funny
is I fork a Dick and a glory.
What's this world coming
to? Fucking Twitter. You are
useless. Your Dad was right,
but I have found that like when,
uh,
when people will tweet something negative
to me, which is constantly, if I reply,
if I spent half a second to reply and
let them know that I actually listened to
their criticism or, you know, I'm sorry
you thought that what I said was terrible,
but here's why I believe it was just
that ounce of attention actually makes
people Apollo. I mean certainly there
are trolls. Certainly there are trolls,
but I've been,
I've been pleasantly surprised at how
open people are once you kind of call them
out on, you're kinda being a Dick Right
now, but I do respect your opinion.
It's really funny. Yes. I'm that equalizer
possible.
Yeah.
A lot of times we're just trying to get
a reaction and certainly there is just,
there's a lot of cons out there that are
just jealous to the jealous of the fact
that they know who you are and
you don't know who they are,
so they lash out at you just because of
that. They see you on the show is like,
he's not even really a geek.
I'm a real deep,
I love the Geek test. I love
that. They're so silly. Yeah.
People love just like things going in.
Like if you ever gone on a fucking website
that reviews cars and dudes will go
on about how automatic
transmissions are for fags.
Dude's we'll have like like,
oh wow, automatics are gay.
They'll like get angry.
You don't shift. You don't even get to
put your hand on a knob. How gay is that?
Think really. You get so connected to
the road. It's like almost the vibration.
Anything to be angry about it, they'll
find anything to relate to anything.
You know what I mean? Many people are
mad at us for shitting on windows today.
I bet a hundred tweets.
Oh you mad facts.
Just don't understand
what a run time error.
I love it.
I recently bought a gaming laptop and
was like tweeting out about it and I'm
like, this is great. And you know, not
only did I get from the Mac fans, I got,
oh you went back to windows,
you're running a windows
machine. That's a mistake.
Then from gamers who should be,
who should be supporting anybody
who's playing PC games or laptop.
Oh that must be cause you
love Dick in your eye. Right.
That's why you went for a laptop because
you didn't get a tower and you didn't,
oh you didn't water
cooler, whatever. Yeah,
you don't even overclock
and at some guy got,
I yelled at the Nvidia Graphics Card
Company. I was having a problem.
They weren't supporting
the hardware that I bought.
He spent thousands of dollars on a machine
and they don't officially support the
hardware that's in it yet. Like you
couldn't download a driver for it.
First World fucking problem.
I'm well aware of that,
but I was against it and I tweeted it
out and I got so many people that were
like, dude, download the Linux
distro driver. Happy the inf file.
Fucking right. Here's a five page tutorial
and how to do it. Fucking get it going.
And I'm like, really? That's not,
that's not worth my time or money.
And that's how you're
choosing to chastise me.
I appreciate that people are into
that. I appreciate it. Totally.
I used to be one of those guys,
but Linux computer and I used to,
I was a Unix guy.
I was a coder like for sure.
But did you do like what is the most
impressive piece of code? You have a road?
Um,
well I shouldn't say that.
I,
I guess that was more load balancer
and stuff for like, uh, for,
for routers and stuff.
So I would balance the way packets
were distributed and the uh,
the boxes at an ISP.
Oh really?
So you worked at an ISP balancing pack
and that was one of many yeah, jobs ever.
You do that, what do you do? I
was at work go into, go into inf,
well not nine to five,
but you go into files and basically
look at the way packets are routed by IP
address and packet type and you assign
priorities to them and you make sure that
the servers can talk to each other.
So one servers and taking on everything.
It's distributing this sort of
network load against everything else.
But I mean that was, there was
that there'd be phone tech support.
They would be writing visual
basic installers for windows
three one and dealing
with wind sock errors and all sorts of
crazy shit when the barrier to entry to
get online was actually pretty fun.
Difficult. What year were you online?
Was the first year what? AOL Was it? No,
it wasn't an [inaudible]. That's,
I'm so beautiful. Have male.
I feel so privileged to have
not experienced the internet
through prodigy or AOL.
At first I used something called the
knowledge network routers you is for
serious people. Prodigy was for low.
Remember project did you really?
Customer service.
Okay.
We're going to pretend that
we're calling you and Kevin,
you're the color and you've got
an issue and you call him Brian.
You're the customer service
guy is actually called tech,
which was a company that routed prodigy
because through them and they I did
prodigy and like this is back when call
centers were handled in the u s still,
right? Yeah, so you call ready go Brian.
I want to know how you're
going to fucking greet me.
I'm not going to be greeted on the
customer needs to be a spiel. Hello,
my name is Brian and my ticket
master one thing's gone.
Ticketmaster, where American Express
is the preferred method of payment.
This call may be monitored for quality
assurance purposes by a supervisor.
This is Brian speaking.
How can I help you?
You can American Express
right off the bat,
the preferred preferred sponsor,
what's that all about?
And they would probably paid for
that little shit. There's a kickback,
well amax does
early like if,
if you'd let you,
I'm certain Amex cards get you early
access to certain ticket master events.
It's all one big promotional
kickback madness sons.
It was crazy throwing a live
event and seeing just how that,
that industry needs to be disrupted.
So bad for live events like ticket
sales, like we want it. We, we were,
we were charged charging
essentially a $7 ticket for lead up.
That's what we were asking,
which turned into a $25
ticket after convenience fees,
processing charges, the house gets
their cut like everything on our ticket,
$7 and it ended up costing 25.
And that's what it has to do that
when I do concerts and, uh, in,
in certain venues, but after to
feel like they have to get paid to,
why else would they have a theater if
they're not getting money? Well, the, the,
the theater, the theater is getting a very
small fee on that, on that ticket fee.
Right?
They're getting a very small amount that
he was gonna make their money off of
the door and are off of, off of
parking and off of food and beverage.
Mosley who's fucking
you then? Um, you know,
I think they're still partners on some
of our leadup tours that we haven't
completely divorced ourselves.
But I love what Louis C K is doing,
going completely independent and saying
there's certain companies that venues,
and in some areas they own every
fucking venue that's worth a damn.
And there's some bands that
have exclusivity with those
venues. So if they tour,
they have to play in one of those
venues and use their ticketing systems.
It's all designed to maximize their
profit and make it fucking impossible for
you to make one as a small event in a big
venue. Um, and it needs to be disrupted.
And the notion of, I guess you could
kind of kickstart or something,
but there should be a site or service
where people can demand an event in their
area. And if enough people
demand that, then you can,
you can take bids from local venues, you
know what I mean? To disrupt that model.
So you're not picking a venue first,
trying to guarantee a certain number of
ticket sales and then going on sale and
trying to drum up publicity.
Hmm. Um, I,
I could see your point in
that if you are doing this,
you can force bands to
pay to charge much more.
But is it because the people,
they have contracts to keep steady work
coming in because otherwise, I mean,
how much steady work is going
to come into these theaters?
I don't know how that
business really works.
I think it's, I think it's, I think they
have, I shouldn't say half the time.
I really don't know that the numbers
there, but how those metrics shake out.
But I believe they are purchasing venues,
ticket agents, they own the venue.
It's there.
Don't they have agreements with like,
like talent agencies and
how do they work all that
sometimes. Um, yeah. I don't
know what specifics I could
get into like, yeah, yeah.
It's,
what do you think specifically
should be disrupted?
You think that it's too difficult?
It's too easy to control the market.
Is that what it is?
Yeah. Well, I mean it's, you're, you're
locked out. If you want to play a,
if you want to play a certain
type of venue in certain cities,
you have no choice but to
go with a certain ticketing
agency that has their own
built in fees and system. And at one
ticket age he has a deal with the vent.
They have an agreement with the venues
or sometimes they own the venue.
But don't you think
because they can provide the ax to the
venue, isn't it the idea behind it? Um,
sometimes, but you know, as an
independent who isn't signed on with that,
you still have to play that game. You
know what I mean? You don't have a choice.
You literally don't have a choice in
certain areas with certain venues.
But what I think needs to be disrupted
is the notion of we're going,
like if you're going to go tour,
you pick your dates and your clubs
probably based off of metric,
ton of data or off of Twitter.
And then you say,
we're going to go to these things and you
go on sale and you have to promote and
hope you sell those tickets
and hope that goes through.
I think there needs to be a Kickstarter
style model where people can,
within like you can pick an area and so
within, you set a radius a hundred miles,
200 miles. I want to throw an
event here, describe your event.
And then as people like on Facebook
or whatever, or they donate,
I'm going to spend $20 on that event for
a little extra bonus and become an, uh,
an evangelist of your
brand or of your tour.
So I'm going to sign up more people and I,
I'm incentivized to sign up people.
I think you can,
you can see what the demand is in an
area first and incentivize early adopters
to raise publicity about your event by
giving them kickbacks or stickers or
extra merged or whatever
for being an evangelist.
And that way when you launched the tour,
you already know you've presold x amount
in those areas because people have
committed. So it's not like Kickstarter
for touring. That's an interesting idea.
Yeah, that's a great idea. I'm just
what I want to do. That's what you want.
Do sure. I want to do again and again
and again and again. You said it live,
that's doing it. I started
to do it actually like, uh,
I started to do it and,
and just realized I have too
many plates spinning right now,
so someone wants to do that. Awesome. I
hope you do. I'd love to use that service.
And if you want me on the advisory board,
fuck yeah. But I just don't have the,
you know, I'm, I've got
a lot of plates spinning.
So the way it is is the big venues
and nice places are all locked up.
Pretty much. Yeah. Pretty much.
Hmm. And uh, yeah, I mean,
you have to go with the, there's,
there's Ticketmaster venues,
so if you want to play a certain venue,
you're paying ticket master
that's happening. Didn't, oh,
who's the band that tried to Seattle?
What? The Pearl Jam. Pearl Jam.
And they, I mean, they did
for their fans, but you know,
that's like Radiohead saying anybody
can release an album for free online.
It's like, well, you can, if
you've reached a certain size
right. You know, if your,
if your Pearl Jam,
you can fight back against Ticketmaster.
If you're trying to throw a night of
comedy together or throw together a nerd
carnival and you, you know,
you, you have to play by their
rules. Right, right, right.
Yeah, it's wild. That's
interesting. And it's, well,
it's hard to run a fucking venue out.
Imagine man, let a thankless Gig.
I have a bunch of assholes come and put
on fucking shows at your place. Really?
Cops behind. Well, I mean, that's
part of you. I mean that's, you're,
you're paying for someone to
clean up their venue. You're
always paying for that.
It's not like, you know, that's,
that's built in and that's why
the venue should get their charge.
If they're throwing the event there,
then sure you're paying for them to
staff people to clean it up and make sure
microphones work and lights work. I
mean, that's what you're paying for, but,
but $17 for a convenience fee.
What?
There's nothing convenience convenient
about that. What is the convenience for,
you know, it all depends. It's a sliding
scale on a certain price ticket. It's a,
there's a builtin fee plus a percentage.
So you have to price your tickets at
a certain way so that you don't end up
fucking everybody else over and you
end up losing money on that front.
That sounds like a viewer more successful
though. And you sold more tickets,
you wouldn't have that problem. Yeah. Make
money. Yeah. You, you can't, you look,
you can certainly make money off
ticket sales. That's absolutely sure.
Even how to even handle our ambassador
and how all these companies like lock
everything down like this.
Uh, well at one point in time,
I think they were a very convenient and
they were sort of the only game and then
they, then they started going to events
and doing, you know, deals with them.
You're going to sell your tickets
through ticket master and nobody else.
And look, we're online and breezy and
we're great and customers love it.
And then once that wasn't trenched and
they bought their deals and do deals with
people who own the venues, then they
lock you out and keep power. I mean it's,
I think it's a snobby, there's certainly
companies that are trying to disrupt it,
like Brown paper tickets.
They're trying to do independent ticketing
for events I used for the last one.
Yeah, there's, there's,
there's a lot of companies that are
trying to disrupt that space but to throw
events at certain venues, the granted
they're nice venues, the great venues.
That's why we chose club Nokia.
I mean it was phenomenal.
Great venue and I loved everybody that
worked there. It was a great experience,
but it's just unfortunate that you'd want
to charge $7 for something and because
of the system that's entrenched around it,
you end up charging 25 that's sad.
That hurts, you know? That's,
that's triple what we want
to charge, you know? Right.
It's still only 25 bucks.
You stop complaining,
so lead up is going to be like people are
going to perform. You're going to have,
I want it to be, I want it to be in a
carnival, a true carnival atmosphere.
I want you to be able to play
skeeball wear of bow tie. When weird.
Are you going to let be a weird host?
I'm going to put on that thing,
that green suit with the question marks
on it like either like the government or
the guy that's selling your
things on this. That's the
question mark to face guy.
Well, hello nerds. Let me pander to you
for an hour.
Yeah,
you're going to have to do something
to stand out as the promoter,
perhaps something with feathers.
Would you be willing or interested in
wearing a boa? Absolutely. I would.
I would rock a,
I would rock a bow on stage.
Like how many guys who are the host have
to like where do something flamboyant,
like have a cigarette in a cigarette
holder or that Sam, he's the host,
see him with a cigarette and the
cigarette holder, he's our host.
I love how we're opening this year's tour.
I'm Mike rounds coming along,
so I'm gonna play drums with them
for a little bit of it's set in. Oh,
he's an Mac.
Mike Brown is a phenomenal VJ.
He's one of the guys that spend those
visuals. He's close to the Olympics.
He's toured it, the blue man
group. Like, oh, he's pro VJ.
Like he's the Tso objs. Is that what I
think? So I put them on that on that part.
Yeah, absolutely. He does remixes for, Oh,
you're getting hypnotized by
our first lead up promo. Um, he,
uh, he's one of those guys that will cut
all the trailers for official movies and
films and stuff like that.
All the remix trailers.
But we're opening it up at that old,
uh, Hbo, eighties thing. You know,
like Hbo would play before every
movie where you fly over the city
flying to the letters.
Diana,
we're doing that and remember that.
It's one of my favorite.
Oh good. And, and the documentary on them
making that is brilliant. They were like,
they invested so much money and building
a little stop motion animated town that
the camera could fly over and they
comped in the average family watching TV.
Like what?
Gathering around,
watch HBO and the camera flies over
the city and goes into the stars.
It was a beautiful piece of advertising.
You need to explain to me how you don't
like game of Thrones because I just
don't understand you.
Well that's,
I got to give it three episodes
because I've watched the first one.
It was a lot of talking and you know,
a lot of people said the same thing.
I did took like five episodes
for some people. I know, I know.
I was in the minority of people.
Lot of people got upset about that.
But those people get upset
about windows users tears
this to, this defines,
yeah, this is my charter
HBO time.
It sound design in the cars
fake. Hell yeah, they did.
Beetlejuice is going to pop out of one
of those buildings. Any seconds build up.
Here we go.
Some dude at synth in
the studio is rocking.
Whoa.
Feel spacious.
But Center at board it.
And let's go into this hero. Yes. Oh
Wow.
Factory period.
Right there.
I got to tell you that I have forgotten
about that on 100% completely.
That was what you were bringing it back.
Sort of barely remembered and that great.
But that was something that had been
a wreath from my mind. Fuck yeah,
we're bringing that bag. If we're doing
a, we're doing a hardcore electronic,
a double bass, just oh man. Yeah. That's
all we're going to open this remix.
Yeah. Wow. So you're going
to, you're going to have this,
you're going to have the VJ,
you're going to have a what podcasts
are going to perform. Uh, well,
right now I'm just sort
of leading the night,
like a epic mealtime's coming
with us for most of the tour.
Hardly in the guys at mealtime.
Brilliant Youtube series where guys like
make like 900,000 Calorie burgers and
pizza.
So they'll go to every fast
food restaurant and get
one of everything on the
menu,
roll it up into a deep fried dough thing
and then eat it and put Jack Daniels
all over it. Oh my. It's brilliant. It's a
great, it's, there's epic music behind it.
The cuts are great. They're buying 40
pounds of Bacon at the supermarket,
filling up the shopping cart and just
make these high caloric things and just
eat them.
So hardly came out at the first one.
And we interviewed him and then we
brought, we built like a youtube. Yeah,
it's a great series on youtube.
Better that or man versus food.
I don't do man versus food. I
do a, I do help to the kitchen
for you. No, no, no, no.
I do hell's kitchen.
Hell's kitchen.
Hell's kitchen is about as mainstream as
it gets and it's fucking love that show.
It's one of my favorites. I Love Gordon
Ramsey getting pissed off about somebody.
Risotto is the greatest moment in my life.
I look forward to them
making fucking horrible.
Must it be for those dudes to go to
or you're working at a restaurants?
I'm shit restaurant. He'd been working
at the same shit restaurant forever.
It's always been shit. He just fucking
put out your Shitty Meatloaf, you know?
Let me think about it. And also
gorgeous kitchen. Nice. Right? Yeah.
That's kitchen neck.
God love that.
I love how every single restaurant owner
on kitchen nightmares truly believes
they're not going to get
raped by Gordon Ramsey. Yeah.
And then they're just
crying in the kitchen.
Got It's powering into them over the oven.
We've got a good salad.
We've got a good dressing on a salad.
These are good crew times. Yeah.
Where do you store the salad
or the trunk of my car.
We thought we put ice in there once a
week when we get new lettuce and they pull
up like it's fine. Moldy things out
of the frigerator. It's just for,
it looks like cat mixed with how much
of the staged it, none of it stage. No,
no kitchen nightmares.
Definitely not staged.
I actually pawn stars and stuff his stage,
but I mean,
how many shitty disgusting restaurants
are there in La alone that have C's in
the window where you know there's just
sour cream under a pile of dead cats in
the kitchen. Like that shit exists
right now. That's where we stored.
That's where grandpa used to. Yeah.
What do you have to do to get a d?
Have you ever seen a dean at a dairy
queen with a c ones? It was my first
week ever smoking pot and I,
we made a trip five mile walk to a dairy
queen with a c because I decided in an
Oreo blizzard was our fucking holy
grail and I shat myself senseless.
Did you literally?
Oh yeah.
Immediately when we walked back and we
were sober and I was like, that was a,
well that was a trek and then
immediately everybody who wait,
they're like three other guys were
like, ah, later bro. Everyone got sick.
Everybody just, just
screaming assholes. Wow. US.
You have to really go out
of your way to get a c.
It's usually really in restaurants I've
noticed and that's not to be racist or
anything,
it's just that that's what
I've been because I'm like
addicted to looking at the
letters and every,
almost every time I look it's always,
and in restaurant that's like a B or a c.
People beat the drum for deregulation on
everything and yet I wouldn't eat at a
restaurant if half the restaurants,
if I didn't believe that there was a
solid blue letter in the window that was
somehow certified and then
someone was looking out for that.
The fact that we don't want to,
we don't want to monitor what goes into
our food and how it's made and why it's
made like people that are against
labeling foods, those are assholes.
Genetically Modified foods like they're
like, you can't put that on the list.
What the fuck?
Can't you put it on the label?
They're fighting it now they're
finding it tooth and nail GMO foods,
you GMO.
Scary stuff,
man. This is all, I mean some of
it can certainly help people. Sure,
but some of it is real experimental.
They don't know what the fuck's
going to happen. 50 years.
The Shit. They're like, look, we tried
it on a couple rats. Rats did. All right,
how would we think it's safe now?
Crosspollination of other people's
plants, you know, they're,
they're genetically modified plants are
getting into other people's crops and
some that means people
are getting sued for,
Oh yeah,
you're Monsanto corn or yours.
Your seed flew across the other highway
and now I have your trademark corn
growing in my field.
It's what
Monsanto created,
Agent Orange create a DDT like they
created some seriously scary shit before
they started fucking around
with genetically modified.
Well, that's the really skin.
That's the really scary shit. Yeah.
That's what's crazy.
Well,
not only that,
there was speculation for a long time
that they bought blackwater. You know,
blackwater,
you mean XII? Yeah. Xxi I love how
quick she to change to change it again.
Yeah. Agency or something like
that. Something along those lines.
But they were sold by someone in,
the speculation was that they
were sold by black water.
They're sold through some private
corporation and that was the,
could you imagine if
Monsanto bought black water?
Like what if they bought their own
mercenary group because you know they're,
they have, they face like some serious
resistance and other countries,
especially in India,
where in India that something like every
30 seconds a farmer commit suicide in
India because he owes money to Monsanto,
hundreds of thousands of farmers have
committed suicide because they are
involved in depth. They can't
pay off and they just get fucked.
I don't know why they have to
make these deals with Monsanto.
I don't know the intricacies of the
corruption and how it's pulled off,
but they developed this relationship or
these people that that's where they're
getting their seats from and they have to
get their seeds from every year. Right?
Well isn't it that they sell
them like a bacteria resistance,
a strain or a roundup ready styles
strain and they put that in,
but it ends up killing other
things or ends up generating its
own problems and how they got to buy
the solution from Monsato as well.
Like isn't that how that process works?
At, they bury themselves in debt.
I don't know. Think it is. I don't know,
but there's a lot of issues to it. I mean,
if he can go and read it,
I get sad and I just stopped
printing it and go to other things.
When you hear that every 30 seconds of
farmers committing suicide because of it
in, well in Brazil, Brazil just
sued Monsanto and farmers won.
They won billions of dollars. Billions.
I mean, what does that mean? I mean,
does it mean that we have to go to
fucking Brazil to get good food? Right.
It means one less caviar ski do for
somebody at Monsato who was already got
billions of dollars. [inaudible]
might not be a bad place to live.
When the shit hits the fan, I
would be down. I love Brazil. Yeah.
I'll just go get a fucking book
on Portuguese. Do you speak,
I don't use your dad's
Portuguese. He is. Yeah.
I told you he wears the bottle of your
car. He's definitely a Portuguese.
He's got thick black chest hair with
like giant Golden Eagles and crosses
dangling and do it. Really? Oh
yeah. And a great pedo stash.
The amber alert is strong with
him. Really love him. Yeah. He's,
he's full on Portuguese and shout
it with bread rolls at his mouth.
Does he know at family dinners? Has he
been to Brazil? Um, and he's from the uh,
A's or islands. Oh,
that's the worst. Yeah.
I saw a whole special Anthony Bourdain
went there. Great cuisine there. Yeah.
It's supposed to be amazing.
Yeah. Amazing. It's a,
it's a track that I need to take,
but I want to take a road trip to Brazil.
So many Portuguese moved to
Massachusetts and Rhode Island.
What the hell is that about?
And I was it proximity and just getting
his in the first place you fly into
massive amount live in fall
river, Massachusetts. Fall
River, Massachusetts is,
do they have like,
they have a lot of showing a lot of he
beaded sweaters because that's why they
would go down a bunch of different
spots in Rhode Island. Um, there's like,
there was like a whole towns where
people talk Portuguese in Rhode Island,
like a wound socket. I
think that was it. Well,
the socket was a part of Rhode
Island where you would go and uh,
it was like a portal, like a Portuguese
fishing village. Crazy. Yeah.
And I never got a,
are you like in touch with your heritage?
Are you really in touch with your heritage
and your roots and your ethnicities
and all that jazz? It's where we have
to wrap this one. Oh Shit. Three hours.
Somehow or another, it gets too
much time on the, the, the uh,
audio and Fox on the other can say on the
audience. I'm like, I can see that. Well,
that to Jesus Christ, we can rambled
forever. I would love, by the way,
it was sincerely, if you
will, let's figure it out. If
you want to come on and do,
if you want to try it on your,
uh,
your idea of doing like a Q and a
kind of thing. If you want to do that.
One of our shows or something like that
out. But it would, it would have to be,
you know, in a weekend
I have off. Certainly,
if that's the problem is most
weekends I'm doing something. Gotcha.
But I'm trying to do less this year. I've
done less this year. I stopped doing, um,
I don't do all the shows with the UFC
anymore. I used to do all the paper views.
Then I would do the spike shows and then
they sold to FX and Fox and then they
have these fuel shows.
And so I don't do any of those.
I want to do Fox and paper view.
So I miss all,
like there's a show tomorrow night.
There's a,
there's one that's going on tonight
in San Jose. Uh, so the, the,
the way in rather was today the fights
or tomorrow night. So I'm missing that.
Wanting to go to it or no,
you're just, no, no, no, no.
I'm trying to travel less.
Yeah. I'm trying to do,
are you doing that so you can, what are
you focusing that time on? Are you okay?
Cause somebody on his podcast and comedy,
it's more fun to me. It's like the,
the podcast,
one of the things that's happened from
the podcast is somehow or another,
we've developed this gigantic group of
people that are really into the podcast.
And the rabbit. I'm one of them. And
they, oh, thanks man. Absolutely.
I listened to it every, all the fucking
time. Oh, thanks. Yeah. So we owe them,
you know, were, were linked. We,
you mean they've been nice to us and
we're the only ones who can make this
podcast,
so we owe them to keep doing this
and it doesn't even feel like,
like an obligation to me. It
feels like a, like an obsession.
Like I fucking love it. You know, like,
it's like yesterday we had
Tommy Chong today we got you.
Tomorrow we've got this Adam called
cash guy from Adam versus the man.
I hope I'm saying his last name.
Right. Um, but it's um, it's fun. It's,
it's interesting.
I'm learning a lot about,
I'm not even a lot about fucking
human beings. I'm learning a lot,
listening to different people.
So stories and yeah.
Experiences if I may.
Like what are you think the overall
takeaway has been because you've chatted
with some diverse groups of
people and had, you know,
had some interesting like
topics of conversation that,
that repeat themselves from
person to person. Is it,
is there a common thread
that has surprised you at
all or is it pretty much what
you figured when you were getting into
it in terms of the way humans think,
operate,
communicate.
It's,
it surprised me how much positivity
can be generated inside of one group.
That's what surprised me because
that wasn't an intention.
It wasn't intention to
start this thing and uh,
have all these people telling me that
it changes our life and they become this
really positive person and they're just
started to cut out all the negative
bullshit and their life and try to get
a job they really want and try to be
healthy. I never expected
any of that. Awesome.
That has been the most shocking
storyline through the whole thing.
This is just how I live my life and I've
lived my life that way to try to manage
my own reality and to try to,
to try to live a happy existence.
And what I've learned over the years is
that the, um, the nicer you are to people,
the happier you are,
the more nice people you're around,
the happier your life would be.
And if you all just come in,
I've been a content my life.
I think we all have had shitty moments
where we just didn't have good control
over our emotions or our state of mind
or our tension level or whatever the fuck
it was. It made you lash out
when you shouldn't have or
insulted someone when you
could've avoided it or whatever the fuck
it is that made you a contact person at
the moment.
We've what?
We've all done that so we can all know
that it's possible to aspire to a higher
state of consciousness to
a higher state of behavior,
a higher level of behavior and that it
makes you a better person and it enriches
your environment.
Like we all know the one person,
like everybody has a friend that's like
a joy to be around and he's like, look,
Joey d is like a life
of a party type dude.
Like you want to be around him because
he makes you feel good because it's good
feelings and you know,
we all should have something like that.
We all should have,
you know,
aspects of ourselves that we put out there
that people like and they do the same
and then we all benefit from each other.
We all get inspired by each other and we
all grow together and I think too many
people are out there in this world
thinking, you know, I'm going to pull,
could be the bird is more the full girl
and I'm going to fall. Could be the man.
No one's over solds me took a does me.
No one's ever sold as many records as me
and no one's ever had as many downloads
as me.
Your shit sucks because Ai,
they can't make it myself or be,
I'm trying to make it an insecure that
it's better than my shit. Your Shit,
your tastes
music. That is amazing. I don't like, you
know, I know classical music is amazing,
but I don't listen to
it. You know, it's very,
the only time I ever listened
to classical music is,
I'll put it in the background.
Occasionally when I write,
I'll have like a little classical music
in the background if I feel like I'm
into it. But for the most part I like,
I like rock. I like old school rock.
I like like Zeplin, like the door
about dubstep. I'm not really into it.
Oh Man.
Have you heard square Lexis doors
song? Sounds cool. Sounds cool to me.
It's like it's new metal to me.
It has the aggression feeling that old
metal used to give me. To me it's newer.
I give it sounds like 40 Roombas
raping robocop on in. Yeah,
that I don't like it. It's
just that I prefer song. Sure.
I prefer like the battle of Curtis
Lowe to that. You know what I mean?
And if I have to listen, I got to
listen to something. Sure. You know,
I can't listen to everything. I don't
have the time. You know what I'm saying?
I feel Kevin prayer.
I love the fact that you have the balls
to fucking jump off that show. Dude.
It's a very successful show.
You the starter of it, the
creator of it. Thank you.
You had the balls just bail right in
the middle of it was a tough decision.
I'm sure it was, but it's the right
one. You're a bad mother fucker dude.
You can do anything you want now. Thanks
man. You're going to wind up probably,
you're probably better off on
the Internet anyway. You know.
If you ever need any help ever
promoting anything at the drop of a hat,
you just let us know. We'll come
here in the middle of the night, man.
We'll do whatever the fuck we need to
appreciate it. Anytime. Thank you man.
Always a pleasure. We'll figure out a
lead up thing. We'll figure something out.
We'll make something happen.
Dirty bitches comicon.
Cyberspace. Calmacom yeah,
we'll be there Friday night at comicon.
Newbie, Ari Shaffir, Brian Red Ban, Sam,
Tripoli and Wa. Let me look
up if you can, I've, I've,
I've actually should probably
plug on super creative.tv.
You can find a link to our Twitter
account. It's, I'm not gonna explain it.
If you want to follow Kevin on Twitter,
don't try to spell it the name correctly.
Go to my Twitter,
find the link for K,
p e r e I r a and then follow that.
But we're doing flash mob
beer parties at comicon.
So if you follow us on Twitter,
I'm going to tweet out our gps location
and for like an hour at that bar,
the drinks are on me.
Oh, you silly. Silly man.
Follow insane. So thank you for
letting me sit. Beautiful. Please.
I'm so Friday night in America at comicon
will be at the American comedy company
in San Diego. That's what it's called,
American American comedy company.
I'll be there Thursday.
Joe would be there Friday and we
have a 90 shows Saturday. So yes,
tickets are insane.
squad.tv naughty shows were very fun too.
If you never been to one, they're awesome.
And this one, he'll have terra Patrick,
the great terror Patrick
there. Um, all right, that's
the end of this fucking show.
His house tomorrow. That's
right. Tomorrow we have a super
show at the ice house.
This will sell out is in the main room.
So if you want to get tickets, go to
ice house, comedy.com it is dom Irrera,
Greg Fitzsimmons, Ari
Shaffir, Brian Red Band.
I go to Naca,
Ryan Mervis,
Ryan Mervis and Meech and a,
yeah, and it's only 15 bucks.
And we,
uh,
we hang around afterwards and we'd take
pictures and we do a podcast that goes
on while the show was going on.
We will be in the green room preparing
and fucking around and we have a podcast
with all the comics together.
And in my opinion,
it's one of the best podcasts we do.
It's called the ice house chronicles,
and it's only available on death squad.
A test squad is a,
our label on iTunes for all
of Brian's podcast. Brian has,
what are the, how many different
podcasts you have there now?
I'm doing about nine right now.
She's not son locked up. Fuck.
Are you trying to do,
take all these people's time,
kill myself anyway,
a lot of them are very funny,
but the icehouse chronicles is my
favorite. It's just a great hang.
It's a real green room
experience is what it is.
It's us and all of our favorite friends
who are fucking hilariously funny.
And every time people in town,
like I just got a request for Tom
Rhodes who wanted to come to this one.
He was hoping we had one on Friday. He
didn't know. But he's, cause he's in La,
like people are hearing about it and
they want to be a part of it and they're,
they're really fun and they're only
available on iTunes under the desk quad
label. So go there, go
to death squad T. Dot.
TV Buy herself a Hitler cat or
Charlie Chaplin Trick trademarked.
Oh, this is the higher presence is
one of my higher prime made shirts.
This is one of my sillier ones,
but I have a tee shirt company that I
never talk about it. It's higher primate.
If you go to higher-primate.com it's all
like monkeys and psychedelic drugs and
uh,
got some new designs coming in and I've
got a bunch of new things happening and
uh, all that will be done
when my new website is done,
which is also the answer to when my
new comedy special will be released.
I'm doing it Louis C K Style and I'll
be done through my website and it'll all
be done. Uh, when my website is released,
it would soon be within the next
couple months. All right. That's it.
You dirty bitches. Thanks to the
fleshlight. Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link.
Enter in the code name Brogan.
Save yourself 15% off and I'm
alone. Search story. If a man,
thanks to [inaudible] dot com makers
of Alpha brain. Here's my bitches.
I ain't playing.
I take the shit before anything I do.
That's important because I'm
not that smart on my own. I
need help. I need coffee.
I got two mountain dews here. I'm not
fucking around. All right, my friends,
we'll see you tomorrow with the
star of a Adam versus the man.
A very controversial and militant sort
of a Internet program that I love the
fuck out of. So we're going to
have a great time tomorrow as well.
Next week we got a shit.
I've got a lot of things come a little.
I'll tell you guys later.
All right,
go to [inaudible] dot com
use code code named Rogan.
Save yourself 10% off any
of the supplements and go
get yourself some kettle
bells so he can be a
manly man. Alright, Holla.
[inaudible]
right.